Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu.
Wie unsere kleine Welt, mein Name ist Tim Pride Love und ich begrüße alle zur Ausgabe Nummer sechsundsechzig dieser Serie
genauer gemeint ist natürlich Corona Weekly, derzeit gibt's hier nicht viel anderes mit mir und mit Pavel Meier, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Unsere wöchentlicher und äh Wischmob durch durch die Corona-Sauerei, die irgendjemand hier im Flur verursacht hat und man wischt und wischt und wischt und es geht nicht weg.
Das ist wirklich ja das ist echt so eine Sache. Wir haben den sechsundzwanzigsten März.
Äh zwanzig einundzwanzig und in diesem Moment fällt mir auf, was vielleicht auch mal ein ganz gute Zahl wäre ist, die Kalenderwoche,
Wir befinden uns am Ende der Kalenderwoche zwei, zwölf, Entschuldigung, zwölf.
Ich finde ja sowieso Kalenderwochen eine tolle Sache. Eigentlich ich finde Kalenderwochen müssten häufiger benutzt werden. Sind aber nur im Business irgendwie so richtig populär. Dabei sind die eigentlich extrem praktisch.
Find's nicht auch? Ich meine, wir alle orientieren organisieren uns ja eigentlich viel mehr so nach Wochen.
Wie man immer deine Infektionszahlen auch mal sehr schön sehen kann.
Natürlich auch Tage nehmen, ich benutz halt Tagesnummern. Das ist auch schneller, wenn wir uns treffen irgendwie, ja? Am zweihundertzwölften.
Ist aber so, dass sich damit dass das kriegt keiner auf die Kette, das ist einfach zu viel, irgendwie, da muss man zu viel teilen und so und bei KW, ich weiß nicht, also so, dass wir, dass man so zweiundfünfzig, dreiundfünfzig Wochen pro Jahr hat, dass dass versteht so jeder.
Ja, glaube, dass es reine Gewohnheitssache. Wenn wir irgendwie alle damit aufgewachsen wären mit äh Tagesnummern äh das Jahr durchzunummerieren. Dann kennen wir damit.
Verabreden sich auf die Sekunde genau hoch. Ja wir treffen uns bei zehn Millionen dreihundertsiebenundachtzigtausendfünfhundertvierzehn Sekunden.
So, wir müssen reden, Pavel. Was für eine Woche,
Es ist nicht zu fassen. Also ich meine meine Geduld war ja letzte Woche schon so leicht strapaziert, aber diese Woche dachte ich wirklich, jetzt schütte ich gleich den Kaffee in die Tastatur. Erst diese Nummer mit
Wir machen jetzt mal so einen Logdown, der keiner ist.
Die Sicherheitsfeiertage meinst du.
Was auch immer das gewesen sein soll. Also auf der einen Seite fand ich's ja schon bemerkenswert.
Das so äh Angela Merkel sich da zumindest so ein bisschen durchgesetzt hat, überhaupt irgendwas zu machen, weil danach sah es ja nicht aus
Und dann hatte ich mir das auch ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht so genau angeschaut und ich bin gecheckt, dass es irgendwie wirklich nur fünf Tage sind und dann auch nicht durchgehend, weil er dann irgendwie der Samstag,
doch wieder alles offen sein soll oder so? Also ich habe das überhaupt nicht begriffen und dann scheitert es angeblich an.
An an rechtlich auf basis rechtlicher Gründe.
Weil Feiertage beschlossen werden sollen, die dann in der Zuständigkeit der Länder und so weiter, also das klang mir so nach Ausrede. Am Ende kann da einfach nur die Autoindustrie angerufen haben und gesagt haben, Leute, ich lasse das mal.
Ich weiß es nicht. Auf jeden Fall wachen wir am Dienstag auf, ja? War das der Dienstag? Ich glaube ja.
Um dann zu lesen ja alles wieder Rolle rückwärts und dann muss ich ausgerechnet Angela Merkel dafür entschuldigen.
Dass sie was vernünftiges gewollt hat.
Geht.
Zwar hin und vorne niemals gereicht hätte und jede Kritik verdient hätte. So, aber sogar das wurde dann mit mit dem Gang zu Canossa bestraft.
Und dann fing gleich wieder alle an, das hohe Lied der Lockerung zu singen, so nach dem Motto, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, jetzt können wir ja mal richtig aufmachen und das Saarland macht dann alles auf und nach Ostern wird's richtig geil und überhaupt und
die Lockerung hier lockerung da und dann ging das irgendwie so einen Tag oder zwei.
Ja, aber lasst mich kurz nochmal was zu den äh äh zu den Feiertagen sagen, weil ähm also.
Was man wohl gewollt hat oder Angela Merkel wohl
gewollt hat, ist quasi Feiertage einzuführen ohne Feiertage einzuführen. Äh so weil
Ja, sozusagen quasi Feiertage, die das dieselbe Wirkung haben sollten wie Feiertage, aber eben keine gesetzlichen Feiertage sind, weil.
Das Problem ist, äh dass eben ja die Regierungen keine Feiertage erlassen können.
Und äh die Bundesregierung sowieso nicht, sondern dass es halt komplett Ländersache. Also jedes Land hat sein eigenes Feiertagsgesetz, deswegen sind auch in jedem Land gibt's andere Feiertage.
Mehr oder weniger. So, das heißt, mit Feiertagen hat die Kanzlerin sagen, erstmal doppelt nichts zu tun. Also erstens, weil sie bunt ist und zweitens, weil sie Regierung ist.
Und die ganzen Ministerpräsidenten hatten waren auch nicht
in der Lage sagen richtige Feiertage anzuordnen, sondern das müssen die Landesparlamente beschließen, so. Und das ist natürlich Änderung des Feiertagsgesetzes innerhalb einer Woche, das ist sportlich
und ne und ich meine, wir hatten ich weiß das nur deswegen, weil wir im Abgeordnetenhaus
damals diesen zusätzlichen Reformationstag eingeführt haben, so einen einmaligen Feiertag und dann kamen halt auch die
'n Antrag damals von SPD und CDU, der dann vorgelesen wurde, ja der Senat möge doch bitte
den äh Tag zum äh Feiertag erklären. Wobei wir dann erstmal dann erklären mussten, dass der Senat das nicht kann, dass sie dass sie dieser Antrag totaler Quatsch ist.
In die Piratenfraktion.
Ja, ja, genau, genau. Mhm. Also Simon weiß, äh, hat dazu damals gesprochen, weil Silo und hat sich halt köstlich darüber amüsiert, dass halt die Regierung keine Ahnung von Feiertagen hat, ja.
Und ja, sowas ist ähnliches, ist wahrscheinlich.
Hier auch passiert. Irgendwie hatte das wahrscheinlich niemand so richtig aufm Schirm äh, dass wenn man,
Das feiert mit Feiertagen machen will äh so, dass man dann halt
Gesetzesänderungen in sechzehn Bundesländern braucht. Man dachte, man kann das irgendwie anders machen. So, aber ähm für Feiertage ist alles geregelt, es geregelt,
Überstunden äh bezahlt äh
werden an Feiertagen da es geregelt, was aufmachen darf und was nicht und irgendwie tausend andere Dinge steuerlich und sozialversicherungsbeiträge und hast du nicht gesehen, ja.
Wie wer auf der, welche Autos auf der Straße noch fahren könnten, so LKWs und so, also er häng
halt ein Riesenschwanz dran an so einem Feiertag. So, dann haben sie festgestellt, okay, echte Feiertage äh kriegen wir nicht hin
und was müssten wir denn tun, um jetzt irgendwie quasi Feiertage gesetzlich zu fahren kann und haben sie festgestellt, wow
Nee, komm mal, komm mal nicht. So, insofern waren jetzt diese rechtlichen Probleme nicht vorgeschoben, sondern ja
das war einfach mal gewollt und nicht gekonnt so
Muss man sagen, klarer Fall von gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Aber was sollte denn dieser Sport überhaupt? Ich meine, warum hat man nicht einfach einen Lokdown gemacht? Das hat doch schon mal funktioniert.
Hier, ja, ja. Ja, hätte man tun können, aber ähm ja.
Das ist wirklich also also.
Die Infektionsschutzverordnung, aber äh ja.
Als ob wirklich, also ich ich gehöre ja, ich geb's jetzt mal zu, ja? Ich dachte ja auch, dass es da sind irgendwie genug.
Erwachsene im Raum und Leute, die irgendwie diese ganze Politgeschichte schon lange noch machen, dass sie irgendwie mal checken, wie so der Hase läuft und dass wenn sie sowas beschließen.
Das ist selbstverständlich schon Wochen vorher durchgeprüft haben. Vor einem Jahr schon durchgeprüft haben, als sie diesen Logdown gemacht haben, welche Optionen es denn gibt.
Ich meine, wenn das dann über die Infektionsschutzverordnung läuft, das ist natürlich das Problem, dass der Staat äh dann äh,
entschädigen muss. So, der kann nicht einfach irgendwie.
Anordnen. Hier ist jetzt dicht, sondern äh äh so. Und da hatte man dann halt, das wollte man halt auch nicht ähm zu, dass das also man wollte halt kein Geld ausgeben dafür äh dass dann zugemacht wird.
Weil dann.
Kämen halt irgendwelche weiß ich nicht, Fabriken, die man vielleicht VW an und würde sagen, ey, wir haben das jetzt alles schon eingeplant, da kommen irgendwie unsere ganzen Lieferungen und wenn wir jetzt
wie den Betrieb nicht öffnen können an dem Tag, dann ja die Leute Feiertage machen, dann fällt unsere ganze Produktion zusammen und deswegen hier äh hundertsechsundzwanzig Millionen hätten wir jetzt gerne äh
so wegen dem Chaos.
Was in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar ist. Nur das Dinge ist, das hilft ja alles nix. Also jetzt.
Jetzt haben wir das Problem ja gleich noch äh krasser. Wir werden gleich nochmal viel über Zahlen und Voraussagen reden, aber man sollte sich eine Zahl gleich immer wieder mal im Kopf schreiben, so. Jeden Tag, den wir jetzt warten.
Zwei Tage nach hinten raus.
Der ganze Scheiß noch länger dauert. So und jeden Tag ist Week. So, heute ist nichts gemacht worden, wieder zwei Tage länger äh in irgendeiner eingeschränkten Situation sein. Und.
Das ist so bisschen das das Grundproblem. Aber was ich jetzt eigentlich noch viel krasser fand, wenn man jetzt vielleicht mal diese rechtlichen Implikationen äh dieses Osterlockdowns wegnehmen, ist halt einfach was äh seitdem passiert ist
nämlich gar nichts. Stattdessen starren sie jetzt irgendwie wie das Karnickel auf die Schlange und jetzt kommen so die Kommentare hoch mit
Ja, also die Zahlen sehr total beunruhigend nicht, ja? Und heute war Pressekonferenz beim RKI und der Wider dann so, na ja, also es ist ja jetzt mal, sieht ja mal richtig Scheiße aus und wenn das so weitergeht, dann haben wir so hunderttausend infizierte pro Tag und dann haben wir auch wieder ganz viele Tote und überhaupt und die
die Krankenhäuser werden schon wieder voller und ja der Kollaps steht an und auch der Spahn sitzt dann daneben und sagt so, ja, das ist ja alles total bedrohlich.
So ja.
Wahnsinn. Wahnsinn. Mhm.
Dafür, dafür müsstet ihr jetzt bis Ende März warten, irgendwie, das wissen wir irgendwie seit seit einem halben Jahr. Geht diese Diskussion so und gefühlt ist irgendwie nichts passiert, so.
So und jetzt sind wir halt schon voll wieder äh im Modus dritte Welle
und keiner, keiner, keiner checkt's. Und alle erzählen jetzt irgendwas von Lockerungen. Jetzt kriegen sie die kalte Füße, weil sie dann ein paar Leute nach Mallorca, weil das Außenministerium dann irgendwie gesagt hat, ach gucke mal,
Auf Mallorca, da ist ja die Institanz unter fünfzig. Da müssen wir da die die Reisesperre wieder aufheben. Ja, sag mal.
Haben die die Telefonnummer von den anderen Leuten in die Insa-Regierung und in den Ministerien kennen die sich, sind die sich schon mal vorgestellt worden, reden die überhaupt noch miteinander, was sowas für Implikationen hat? Natürlich
buchen dann die Leute irgendwie in Mallorca Urlaub, weil auf einmal gar keine Restriktionen sind, da musst du irgendwie.
Nicht testen, wenn du zurückkommst. Es gibt keiner Quarantäne und dann fliegen die da jetzt so hin. Denken sich auch so, ja,
Hab so Interviews gesehen mit so Leuten, die so fahren jetzt nach Mallorca. Tja, ich hab ja jetzt ein Jahr lang ähm.
Hier sind wir alles so mitgemacht und jetzt muss auch mal gut sein. Mal da.
Irgendwann muss er mal gut sein.
Das kann ich, kann ich emotional, kann ich das halt nachvollziehen so, ne? Das Problem ist nur, du kleiner Scheißer. Du fährst dann nach Mallorca und du und holst sie uns irgendwie P eins ins Haus. Und was ist jetzt in Mallorca?
War großartig. Oh.
Nee, ja, Oli.
Ich leide.
Ich glaube, wenn die Spanier Ausgangssperre äh meinen, äh, sagen, dann meinen die auch Ausgangssperre.
Das können die so richtig.
Es ist nicht so wie in Deutschland da, also zumindest ich bin mir jetzt in Spanien nicht ganz so sicher, doch in Spanien war's auch ziemlich heftig, also.
Spanien war das super krass. Da durften die Leute grad mal mit dem Hund irgendwie fünf Minuten raus. Das war's dann aber auch.
Mit Passierschein nur du musst es dann halt selber dir ausfüllen äh so und darfst dich nur
so und so vielen Meter von deinem Wohnort äh von deinem deiner Wohnung entfernen, irgendwie ein Kilometer oder so.
Ja und auch so richtig mit Polizei auf der Straße und.
Und nur zu bestimmten Zeiten.
Sie sind auch nicht so nett wie in Deutschland. Und in Deutschland sind sie ja eigentlich schon nicht so nett.
Ja, also jetzt sitzen sozusagen die Mallorca-Urlauber da in Mallorca am äh im Hotel und können sich sozusagen den Strand von ihrem Hotelzimmer aus angucken.
Ich meine, keine Ahnung, wie das in der Praxis ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist es dann doch wahrscheinlich wieder ein bisschen anders, aber.
Ja, also werden sehen, aber im Moment jedenfalls ja diese Lokdown-Geschichte ist auch äh glaube ich ziemlich frisch, also werden wir sehen wie äh das dann läuft.
Genau, so und dann hatten wir ja vor zwei, drei Wochen haben wir ja Anfang, was war das? Anfang März, siebter März, vor drei Wochen war das, ne? Da haben wir ja die Beschlüsse, diese Lockerungsbeschlüsse durchgegangen. Und im Prinzip ist ja alles jetzt eingetreten.
Was da drin scheint. Da so, ja, also Lockerung schon irgendwie, aber wenn fünfzig bis hundert die Institenz ist, dann vielleicht nicht ganz so viel und ab hundert muss das auch alles wieder auf den Stand vom vor dem siebten März zurückgerollt werden.
Was halt bedeutet Schulen dürfen immer noch geöffnet sein.
Friseure auch.
Freunde, friss Friseure auch, genau ja und.
Aber alle anderen Lockerungen, ja, sind dann wieder Makulatur. Das heißt, es müssten eigentlich die Läden auch wieder zumachen. Machen sie dann aber nicht.
Weil dann halt solche Landräte daher kommen und Bürgermeister und dann so.
Also wir können diesen Sendungstitel vom letzten Mal, den können wir jetzt eigentlich auch gleich gleich nochmal in den Titel reinschreiben, ne? Das, das, das muss man echt nochmal wiederholen, das ist wirklich so dermaßen unfassbar dieser Satz.
Wären eigentlich gefordert zu handeln
haben uns aktuell aber anders entschieden. Und genauso kam's dann halt auch wieder so. Erst war dann so hundert, naja, hundert, na dann machen wir mal zweihundert draus oder so ja hundert und jetzt müssen wir das wieder zurückfahren, aber das können wir jetzt nicht wirklich machen, weil das ähm
Das wäre ja nicht so schön. Und ich stelle mir auch in Portelläden, ja. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass du jetzt mal einen Laden mal eben mal aufmachst
gerade so Restaurants oder sowas oder über die nochmal ein anderer Fall, keine Ahnung, was jetzt der Rahmenparameter sind, aber die sind auf jeden Fall auch alle
alle sind von dieser ganzen Situation genervt, aber was halt wirklich am allermeisten nervt, ist hü
und Hot und Hot und Hü und vor und zurück und locker und nicht mehr so locker. Keiner weiß, was Phase ist. Es gibt keinen Plan. Es ist total planlos und die Pläne, die dann gemacht werden,
die sind dann innerhalb von einem Tag Makulatur, weil sie entweder
rechtlich nicht zu halten sind oder ob sie praktisch dann einfach nicht durchgeführt werden hier in Berlin. Ich weiß nicht um Milet Mayvery, Grundschulen machen auf, ja, weil wir haben ja Schnelltests.
Jetzt ist irgendwie Ferienanfang, kein Schnelltest gesehen. Doch, weil ist nicht da. Konnte nicht geliefert werden. Sorry.
Na super. Das hat ja toll funktioniert so. Aber immerhin so ein bisschen geöffnet so. Dann waren die halt jetzt irgendwie an zwei, drei Tagen die Woche mal da. Das hat jetzt auch nicht viel gebracht, ne?
Genau und haben dann einen Film geguckt.
Das war auch eine Meldung, ja wo ihr sagt, der hat jetzt irgendwie sein Kind in die Schule geschickt und äh dann wurde halt im in der Unterrichtsstunde wurde halt ein Film geguckt.
Nein. Oh.
Wirklich also am Fainting, es ist einfach mir geht langsam wirklich die Schmiere aus.
Na ja genau und dann ja gestern ja noch die die Saarland
Nachricht, die die rein kam, irgendwie Saarland beendet nach Ostern den Logdo.
Wird massiv seine Chornabeschränkungen lockern und weite Teile des öffentlichen Lebens wieder hochfahren. Unter anderem sollen dann Außengastronomie, Kinos und Fitnessstudios wieder
öffnen auch die Kontaktbeschränkungen werden gelockert. Dafür erklärte Ministerpräsident Hans das Saarland zur Modellregion.
Ja, ich meine, man muss dazu sagen, äh dass äh das Saarland äh bisher,
recht gut dasteht sowohl was die Institenz angeht als auch den Ehrwert, also die Zahlen sinken da noch so aber das kann man ja auch ändern ja.
Wahrscheinlich fühlt sich das Saarland gerade irgendwie äh ne. Irgendwie äh überall steigen die Institutionen und bei uns sinken sie, das kann nicht richtig sein. Ja, das müssen wir jetzt dringend
ja umdrehen und ich glaube das werden die auch schaffen.
Sinken sie wirklich, also nach laut deiner Tabelle, also steig langsam durch deine Tabelle nicht mehr durch. Du hast ja so einen RWK von unter eins, aber der offizielle RKI äh RWT vom Saarland ist ja über eins.
Ja, hm, lass mich mal schauen.
Ja, ja, das ist wieder das, das, ich meine, es ist das übliche Problem.
Dass äh je nachdem wie man rechnet gerade. Ähm.
Und zwar, wenn man die Zahlen, die in den letzten sieben Tagen veröffentlicht wurden, mit denen die in den sieben Tagen davor veröffentlicht wurden.
Sind die Zahlen um zwölf Prozent gesunken. So, ähm ja vergleicht man jetzt aber,
Die Zahlen, die vor sieben Tagen.
Lang sich in den letzten sieben Tagen beim Gesundheitsamt gemeldet haben und,
die sich jetzt in den letzten sieben Tagen beim Gesundheitsamt gemeldet haben, dann ist es in der Tat so, äh dass wir eine neunprozentigen Anstieg haben, da ist so vollkommen
Recht. So, nichtsdestotrotz ähm ja äh.
Also, das ist auf jeden Fall keine stabile Situation. Man kann nicht sagen, das Saarland hat fallende Zahlen und äh die können jetzt schon mal öffnen, weil es eh gleich äh alles vorbei mit Corona.
Ja, beziehungsweise sieht es so aus, als wenn sich das Hits gerade in dieser Woche gedreht hat. Also Saarland,
ist halt sozusagen schon hat bundesweit auf jeden Fall die niedrigste Inzidenz so, aber äh eben mit einundsechzig Komma eins äh offiziell.
Und ja. Also so oder so äh.
Äh würde das nicht gut gehen so.
Hat doch gar nichts. Kassel hat noch kein Konora,
das hat mir auch mal als Bonus äh äh trägt, das wurde ja schnell so ein Mehm, irgendwie so eine Frau, die auf der Straße befragt wurde, die meinte einfach nur so, Kassel, Kassel hat noch gar nichts, wir haben, wir haben gar keinen Grundora.
Und jetzt kommt halt so das das Saarland, das Saarland hat noch kein Saarland hat keinen Kondora.
Genau.
Also, um's kurz zu sagen, das Saarland steht nicht.
Es steht besser da, aber nicht gut, ja? Also von der Institenz ist es genauso wie Schleswig-Holstein, aber es ist absehbar, spätestens wenn sie da wieder öffnen, dass sie in null Komma nix wieder auf die hundert zufahren, so wie das alle anderen auch geschafft haben.
Es ist, ich meine, es ist generell, man man hat,
wirklich das Gefühl, dass äh die Politik sich entschlossen hat, die Zahlen absichtlich steigen zu lassen und vielleicht auch möglichst schnell steigen zu lassen, damit möglichst schnell die Leute nach einem
Logdown rufen wieder. Dabei ist es aber eh so, äh dass ja zumindest
nach einer Befragung, äh die ich gesehen habe, eine Mehrheit
Ungefähr sechzig Prozent. Die Maßnahmen entweder für zu hm ja für richtig
oder führt zu lasch halten und sozusagen der eigentlich sogar der größte Teil da der Bevölkerung, ich glaube siebenunddreißig Prozent halten ist für zu lasch
ungefähr, ich glaube dreiunddreißig Prozent waren das äh Finden es zu schlimm, das heißt
im Moment lässt sich die Politik von einer Minderheit, ja, von einem Drittel,
kann man sagen ja treiben und irgendwelche und meint jetzt irgendwie nicht streng sein zu können oder uns den Leuten nichts zumuten
zu können. Äh aber ich ich glaube es ist so, dass jetzt immer mehr Leute.
Langsam begreifen oder früher begreifen, als die Politik, dass das so nicht funktioniert
wie wir das machen, dass äh halt äh ja das einfach nur an die Nerven zerrt und
nicht dahin führt, dass wir halt wirklich lockern können. So, das ist das ist das Problem.
Offensichtlich.
Und ja und das ist, es ist auch ja, ich möchte mir nicht vorstellen, jemand, der jetzt auf äh ja im Gesundheitswesen arbeitet, seit seit einem Jahr
sich da den Hintern äh äh aufreißt und irgendwie die durch die letzte Welle äh noch halt ohne Ende Überstunden aufgebaut hat.
Da habe ich dann auch gesagt, ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass äh einfach äh ja, sich da dann auch irgendwann die Leute anfangen, krank zu melden, so im Gesundheitswesen, weil diese Politik
die einfach krank macht und würde denen auch raten einfach jetzt irgendwie Überstunden abzubauen weil,
äh da kommt halt noch einiges ähm so jetzt und äh ja also.
Dass es eben ja, ich ich versteh's mittlerweile einfach nicht mehr. So.
Was da in den Köpfen einige vor sich geht.
Lass uns mal auf die konkreten Zahlen schauen, wie sie sich jetzt präsentieren.
Ja ähm so ein Blick auf die.
Inzidenzkurve beziehungsweise die Kurve der neuen Felle in den letzten sieben Tagen. Äh ja die steigt halt nicht ganz mit demselben
RWT wie im Oktober aber fast so ähm also hm.
Ja.
Das dauert nicht mehr lange, also wenn man sich das im direkten Vergleich anschaut, war ja am also das ist, wir sind jetzt von den Infektionszahlen, korrigiere mich, wenn ich wieder über falsch liege. Ziemlich
genau da, wo wir am Anfang des Lokdownlight waren, am am Anfang November.
Zweiter, dritter November. So, da war schon seit ein paar Tagen klar, dass dieser Lokdown kommen wird und er hat dann immerhin
vorläufig Mitte November, so nach zwei Wochen ähm den Anstieg gebremst
nicht sehr viel mehr, aber immerhin. Das heißt.
Dem zweiten elften flachte es ganz langsam ab. Wir haben jetzt keinen Lokdown, der heute in in Kraft tritt, ganz im Gegenteil, wir haben Lockerungsdiskussionen und wir haben gerade wieder so einen versuchten,
aufgehoben und wir haben Ostern,
Da muss ich mir nicht äh viel zusammenrechnen. Wir werden definitiv höher als diese erste Abschwächung äh kommen.
Da ist einfach zu viel Schwung drin.
Ja ich mein ja und erfahrungsgemäß wird dann der,
Ähm ja, die zweite Welle ist halt häufig äh einfach,
höher ausgefallen in vielen Ländern oder mindestens gleich hoch, weil es natürlich das Problem mit dem.
Weihnachten, dass die Zahlen da absolut äh sind. Also dass die die Kurve da komplett verstümmelt ist.
Mit zum Zwischenplateau und dann so einem Spike und dann so ein äh irgendwie Abfall und wie der Anstieg und wieder Abfall. Also es ist halt eine zum super hässliche Kurve, die wir da äh produziert haben.
Nächste Woche dann auch mit Ostern.
Ja, super, passt, ja. Passt ja dann.
Genau. Überhaupt. Das ist wahrscheinlich hier wieder die die christliche äh Funktion in dieser ganzen Geschichte das immer zu den großen Kristlichen Festivals ist dann immer irgendwie alles Morks.
Ostern, was kommt da als nächstes? Pfingsten.
Ich mein der RWT muss man allerdings sagen der.
Hält sich, beziehungsweise ist halt ganz leicht runtergegangen, so wir hatten.
Ja den also den sieben Tage R-Wert war der höchste bei eins Komma eins acht meine ich den ich gesehen habe und ähm ja
Aktuell,
Gut, nehmen wir mal, gucken wir mal auch, wie da die Unterschiede in den beiden R Werten nach Melde und Veröffentlichungszahlen eigentlich aussehen. Die sind aber glaube ich ziemlich.
Identisch ja eins Komma eins eins und eins Komma eins zwei, also irgendwo in der Größenordnung liegt er jetzt gerade.
Also lacht ein bisschen zurückgegangen hier.
Aber das sind eben immer noch ja äh rund zwanzig Prozent mehr Fälle.
In den letzten sieben Tagen als in den sieben Tagen davor ja und das wirkt jetzt erstmal eine unbekannte Zeit so weitergehen.
Weil so richtig irgendwie abzeichnen
tut sich da im Moment noch nichts, warum sich das jetzt verlangsamen könnte. Gut, das Wetter könnte uns vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen aushelfen an der Stelle, das das kann irgendwie so null Komma null fünf, null Komma null eins vielleicht
dann ausmachen,
so, aber ja, das wird uns nicht rausreißen. So, das wird uns nicht wirklich rausreißen, aber ich sage mal, jedes hundertstel RWT hilft halt,
So.
Das Hundertstel. Säuft's. Okay.
Ja und mal was gibt's noch zu sagen? Ach so, ja, die.
Genau die Zahl der Todesfälle sinkt jetzt nicht mehr weiter, sondern ja da sind wir so jetzt äh auf einem Plateau angekommen.
Von wie viel.
Ja, es sind nur zweihundert Fälle am Tag, glaube ich, in der Gegend.
Na ja, das korrespondiert so ein bisschen eben mit den steigenden Infektionszahlen schon, ne? Also wir hatten ja ein Prinzip jetzt seit Mitte.
Februar ging's halt langsam wieder nach oben mit den Infektionszahlen, also schon über einen Monat.
Ja? Also tausenddreihundert pro Woche irgendwie ungefähr knapp.
Und normalerweise hätten wir halt jetzt die Impfung nicht gehabt, würden wir das schon längst sehen? Die Todeszahlen wären schon längst hochgegangen. Trotzdem stagnieren sie jetzt.
Aber ähm ja die werden lieber ganz schnell.
In die Höhe gehen, wenn du dir überlegst, dass sie so ja und zwei Wochen hinterherlaufen, meistens ähm.
Du wolltest ja eigentlich auch wieder eine Auswertung der Altersgruppen machen, wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh hat das jetzt aus technischen, weiß technische Probleme gab, haben wir das jetzt nicht für das ganze Land.
Aber man kann ja auch die Zahlen von Berlin schauen.
Genau und da ist es so
weil da da war ja jetzt auch die Debatte aha geht das jetzt wirklich von den Kindern und den geöffneten Schulen aus und haben sich natürlich sofort welche in die Bresche geworfen und gesagt, nee, die Kinder haben damit gar nicht,
tun und ja bei Shit. Ähm weil äh Fakt ist,
Ja, wenn man die absoluten Inzidenzen vergleicht, dann
liegen die Kinder jetzt nicht vorne, sondern das sind dann so
die Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen, also fünfzehn bis neunzehn und zwanzig bis vierundzwanzig sind so die höchsten Institenzen
aber.
Traditionell waren halt die Altersgruppen, was ist traditionell? Ja, jetzt fast schon äh ja, jetzt ein Jahr
Tradition, ja. Aber ähm so, ich sage mal, in der letzten Welle, in der letzten Welle lagen,
die Zahlen unter zehn Jahren
immer so bei der Hälfte bis sogar nur einem Drittel der,
anderen Altersgruppen, der am am meisten Betroffenen Altersgruppen, ja
und also teilweise sogar ein Verhältnis von fünf zu eins. Hattest du auf dem Höhepunkt der zweiten Welle, also
Jetzt zwischen den zwanzig bis vierundzwanzigjährigen bei der Instit und den äh null bis Vierjährigen. Jetzt
Aktuell ist es aber so, dass die fast auf einer Höhe liegendes gabs eigentlich so
ja bei bei hohen Institutionen noch nicht. Es gab mal so letztes Jahr irgendwie in der fünfundzwanzigsten Kalenderwoche äh und dann wieder in der dreiunddreißigsten gab's halt auch mal Auffälligkeiten bei.
Kindern, ähm dass Fahrwahrscheinlich dann auch als dann gelockert wurde und die Kitas wieder aufmachten. Und als dann die Schulen wieder aufgemacht haben, da kommt man dann.
Das waren die einzigen Situationen, aber das war halt bei bei wirklich niedriger Institz, weshalb das nicht so ganz so tragisch war und.
Sind, also sie sind auch ein bisschen früher, also die die ja ich kann sehen der der Anstieg bei den,
fünf bis neunjährigen hat sich so ein bis zwei Wochen vor dem Einstieg in den anderen Altersgruppen
bezeichnet. Also ich würde sagen äh ja es ist also die Zahlen sind eine Smoking dann ähm
durch die äh Öffnung von Kitas und Schulen so ähm ja
Es hat sich das äh sicherlich von da aus äh wieder ausgebreitet ähm.
Also andere Interpretationen äh sehe ich nicht, klar.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht die einzigen so, also jetzt nicht so, dass das nicht auch in allen anderen Altersgruppen äh sich Leute angesteck,
und wir wissen halt, dass vor allem.
Generell in dieser Epidemie die Berufstätigen Altersgruppen am meisten betroffen sind und vor allem die Berufstätigen Frauen, das hatten wir ja irgendwie in der letzten Sendung
und äh ja das ist natürlich dann auch weiter ein Treiber, äh der Pandimi definitiv. Gut sieht's halt bei den ja
über Achtzigjährigen
da ist es so, dass da die Zahlen weiter langsam sinken, aber jetzt auch nicht mehr so wie vor ein paar Wochen oder wie vor ein, zwei Wochen.
Ja und bei siebzig Plus geht's dann auch schon wieder langsam nach oben, ne? Also da ist sozusagen nicht
viel äh gerettet. Also man sieht schon eine Auswirkung der Impfung, aber man sieht eben auch, wer da alles noch nicht geimpft ist und das äh ist äh auf jeden Fall sichtbar, dass da noch nicht genug getan wurde.
Und was wir halt auch immer moniert hatten. Ich habe ja in den letzten Wochen immer also vor drei Wochen oder so zwei, drei Wochen
man sagt, okay, von den reden immer alle, von den über Achtzigjährigen, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt war gerade mal die Hälfte.
Erst geimpft, ja,
Und jetzt nach neuesten Zahlen sind wir was bei siebzig Prozent irgendwo in der Gegend. Erst geimpft und fünfzig Prozent zweitgeimpft. Ja, dass du da.
Genauen Zahlen.
Ja, also das ist es gibt im RKI-Bericht gibt es dazu eine Aufstellung, das Krasse ist, die ist zwar nach Ländern aufgeteilt, aber da sind nicht alle Länder drin, sondern es sind halt nur,
lass mich kurz zählen neun von sechzehn.
Super.
So
neun von sechzehn, wo diese Information vorliegt. Wir hatten das in letzter Woche auch schon, dass manche Länder nicht in dieses Meldesystem für Impfungen angeschlossen sind und dass da irgendwie händisch noch Daten übertragen werden und offensichtlich gibt's aber auch keine klaren Aussagen dazu, wie denn jetzt sozusagen
in den einzelnen Altersklassen dann eben entsprechend geimpft wurde,
und das variiert auch stark zwischen den Ländern. Also wir haben jetzt hier bei den Erstimpfungen liegt das Saarland mit
mit mit etwas mehr als dreiundsiebzig Prozent vorne und du hast äh Mecklenburg-Vorpommern mit äh knapp fünfzig Prozent bei den Erstimpfungen. Bei den Zweitimpfungen sieht's ein bisschen anders aus
da ist das Maximum liegt bei neununddreißig Prozent Baden-Württemberg und geht dann aber auch runter.
Auch wieder Mecklenburg-Vorpommern auf drei an die Schleswig-Holstein bis zweiundzwanzig Komma drei Prozent. Das ist quasi so diese Spanne.
Anderen Worten, wenn man jetzt mal die Zweitimpfung vielleicht mal weglassen, weil wir wissen ja auch, dass schon die Erstimpfung.
Mit Bion Take sehr gute Wirkung zeigt, ne? Haben wir aber,
jetzt hier noch nicht mehr als ich würde mal sagen zwei Drittel durch.
Ich hab jetzt so verschiedene Meldungen gehört mit ja aber die Altersheime sind ja alle durchgeimpft und so aber ich.
Das kann ich jetzt so zur Kenntnis nehmen, aber so einen richtigen Beleg dafür, habe ich noch nicht gesehen und vor allem sehe ich immer wieder auch Anzeichen dafür, dass es eigentlich keiner so genau weiß.
Und ich denke, wenn alle Achtzigjährigen alle achtzig plus jetzt geimpft werden, werden wir da auch keine Toten mehr sehen.
In dem Bereich nicht, aber selbst im Bereich sechzig bis neunundsiebzig äh ist ungefähr im Schnitt ein Drittel.
So hoch, dass das Sterberisiko wie bei achtzig plus bei einer bei einer Kobit-Erkrankung das heißt ähm bei dreimal so hohen Institzen hast du dann doch wieder dieselbe
Zahl und wenn jetzt die Hälfte aber nur durchgeimpft,
ist dann ja äh kann man davon ausgehen, dass sich wahrscheinlich hm das Ganze dann jetzt auf die jüngeren Altersgruppen,
verlagert, das ist einfach mehr jüngere Leute jetzt sterben äh werden, beziehungsweise sind ja,
was ich gehört habe, so sind die Intensivstationen wohl. Jetzt füllen sich zunehmend Fünfzigjährigen.
Viel Spaß. Ja ähm nochmal zu den Zahlen. Ähm Tests, ne.
Mhm. Genau.
Ähm ja, da setzt sich auch der Trend fort, dass sowohl die Testzahlen ansteigen,
aber die Zahl der positiven schneller ansteigt so dass die positiv Quote auch mal auch wieder einen ordentlichen Sprung,
nach oben gemacht hat und,
Ja äh und die die Zahl der Tests sind wir mittlerweile wieder bei eins Komma drei fünf Millionen Tests. Das ist ja schon mal.
Ordentlich das da waren wir dann so irgendwann zwischen Ende Oktober und.
Anfang November letzten Jahres auch, also das das passt von daher auch. Ja und die positiven Quote jetzt bei sieben Komma neun eins Prozent. Das sind.
Zwanzig Prozent mehr oder ein mehr als ein Prozentpunkt äh mehr als letzte Woche noch.
Ja, die positiven Quote aus der Tabelle mit plus fünfzehn Komma vier acht Prozent oder.
Ja, ja, ach so äh ja, habe ich mich in der Spalte verguckt, genau das war die Zahl der positiven Tests, also die sozusagen die,
positiven Tests und die Positivquote sind äh genau fünfzehn Komma vier Prozent. Ähm.
Das muss man miteinander nochmal vergleichen, ne? Also wir haben fünf Komma sieben eins Prozent mehr Tests, aber die Quote.
Derer, die davon positiv sind, stieg um fünfzehn
Komma fünf Prozent und liegt jetzt bei sieben Komma neun eins Prozent und wir wissen WHO sagt, alles was über fünf ist, ist nicht okay und
wir können halt auch an dieser positiven Quote, da werde ich jetzt äh nicht müde, das immer zu wiederholen, weil ich finde, das ist einfach die die rundeste Kurve von allen, die wir bisher äh so gesehen haben, ja.
Die speichert,
quasi jede Dynamik in sich und und drückt einfach total steril diesen Gesamtverlauf aus immer wieder. Und äh du hast es ja auch nochmal visualisiert, das haben wir auch immer äh im Blog
daran kann man einfach am besten sehen, dass der Trend jetzt einfach klar nach oben zeigt.
Und wir sind von der positiven Quote sind wir jetzt wieder bei Mitte November angekommen, so ungefähr, also ja, erste zweite Novemberwoche
um
Genau, das deckt sich ja dann mit den Infektionszahlen. Also wir sind eigentlich genau da, wo wir beim Lokdown.
Beim zweiten Lokdown waren, den sogenannten Lokdown, den Lockdownlight.
Man müsste, man müsste diese Lokdowns irgendwie nach Politikern benennen, so ein bisschen so wie Hartz vier irgendwie Merkel zwei, äh wer auch immer gerade oder Spahn zwei äh am meisten Schuld war, dass es verkackt wurde.
Den Laschet lockt dauern oder den, den Laschet Lockerung. Na ja egal. Ich drehe schon wieder durch. Ganz ruhig Tim, ganz ruhig.
Ja alles alles wird gut, ja.
Müssen wir nochmal ankieken.
Die Varianten. Ähm.
Ich meine, was ja eh klar war, ist, dass äh Korona Classic eine aussterbende Spezies äh ist
und äh
irgendwann praktisch nicht mehr vorkommt, wenn er wahrscheinlich sogar irgendwann auf null geht, weil halt die berühmte britische Mutation B eins eins sieben äh sondern ähm Erfolgsmodell
ist und.
Variante, das ist die Variante. Die Motation ist was anderes.
Okay, die Variante, ja,
Die Variante, die genau eine Reihe von Mutationen umfasst. Gut, präzise. Danke. Ähm und.
So die, genau, die B eins eins sieben Variante hatte jetzt in der KW elf äh so zweiundsiebzig Komma.
Nein, alle Varianten zusammen haben zweiundsiebzig Komma drei Prozent und einundsiebzig Komma drei Prozent aller Infektionen äh entfallen dabei auf die B eins eins sieben. Variante,
und.
Ja äh dann gibt's noch die B eins drei fünf eins Variante. Die ist so am zweitmeisten verbreitet, somit ungefähr ein Prozent.
Das ist die Südafrika-Variante.
Ja ich ist das die.
Oder ja, das ist die oder man könnte auch die Tirolvariante sagen, weil da ist äh hängt hängt eine ganze Menge davon äh rum, aber das ist die Südafrika-Variante, genau.
Genau und dann haben wir noch die P eins und die P eins hat scheinbar noch so ein bisschen Probleme,
Offen Kreuz zu kommen, also ähm ja
die wächst nicht so richtig stark, also sie kann so ein bisschen mit
den anderen Varianten wahrscheinlich mithalten, aber tatsächlich ist die äh B eins eins sieben den Zahlen nach, bisher die virulenteste. So,
Ähm was, ich sage mal, was einerseits.
Gewisse Vorteile äh hat, wenn die anderen Varianten da nicht so zum Zuge kommen,
wegen B eins eins sieben, weil die eventuell ja die teilweise einfach noch schlimmer sind, aber,
mit zumindest, ich glaube mit der P1 Variante äh war
Jawohl, das ist ja wohl auch die Immun-Escape-Variante, die
mit einem höheren, mit einer höheren Wahrscheinlichkeit Reinfektion möglich macht,
sitzt auch die Theorie, dass sie dann deswegen in Brasilien entstanden ist, weil da schon so viele durchinfiziert waren, dass sich das Virus
irgendwie notieren musste, damit sie die alle nochmal anstecken kann, weil,
Ja, äh weiß nicht, was, also ich habe das jetzt nicht nachgerechnet, aber äh zumindest äh ja.
Kann das halt schon sein, wenn du dann eine Bevölkerung hast, wo dann schon vierzig, fünfzig Prozent sich mal infiziert hatten, dann
hat natürlich so eine neue Variante, die die alle nochmal anstecken kann. Äh einen echten Verbreitungsvorteil.
Das wird aber auch bedeuten, dass äh Brasilien sozusagen die Chance hat nochmal äh mehr als hundert Prozent anzustecken. So, absurd, das klingt, ne? Ja, ja.
Und ja da kann man dann halt mehrere da kann man das dann mehrmals also nicht jeder und wahrscheinlich hat's sind dann auch die Verläufe nicht nicht ganz so schwer und so aber trotzdem
ja und da haben wir bei uns natürlich eine.
Noch etwas andere Situationen. Bei uns gibt's noch hinreichend viele frische Opfer in der Bevölkerung
wenn wir mal komplett zusammen
zählen jetzt die die Zahl der Infektionen, dann sind wir ja bald bei.
Ja noch nicht ganz bei der Arbeit, zwei Komma sieben Millionen. Dann nehmen wir nochmal, nehmen wir das mal locker mal drei oder so.
Auf äh Runde acht Millionen. Ja und an wie viel Millionen haben wir jetzt erst geimpft? Ähm.
Nicht viele.
Wir sind jetzt bei zehn Prozent, acht Millionen.
Ja, acht Millionen. Also dann sagen wir so sechzehn Millionen, das heißt achtzig Prozent der Bevölkerung sind noch
immer ja jungfräulich was das Virus oder Impfstoff äh angeht und stehen halt bei uns noch zur Verfügung
als Wirte für das Virus und deswegen hat halt wahrscheinlich im Moment diese die P eins deswegen nicht so den Vorteil wie in Brasilien
Aber das ging natürlich wenn jetzt mit den Impfungen und so ähm muss man, muss man sehen
wie sich wie sich das in der Praxis dann auswirken wird, wie gut die äh dann auch vor der P eins schützen angeblich soll es ja ganz ganz gut funktionieren, aber.
Nicht mit allen Impfstoffen holen.
Ja, also Brasilien ist auch jetzt wirklich echt nochmal so ein Sonderfall, weil diese ganze P1 Geschichte spielt sich ja im Wesentlichen dort ab und Brasilien ist auch ein Land, was es einfach gerade überhaupt nicht auf die Kette kriegt. Das liegt natürlich einerseits an dieser Führung, an diesem Bolsonaro, der das alles irgendwie ignoriert und äh ohnehin so ein totaler Trump ist
und ja, das sind natürlich auch die sonstigen Voraussetzungen
Brasiliens jetzt nicht unbedingt optimal sind in der Bekämpfung und sind natürlich auch äh jetzt nicht unbedingt an so dermaßen viel Impfstoffe bisher rangekommen sind.
Ja interessant ist vielleicht noch dann dazu, weil das RKI hatte jetzt äh auch.
Wir haben einen Einbericht, äh die
äh Virusvarianten mal nach Bundesländern aufgeschlüsselt. Das fand ich halt dann noch ganz nett
und da zeigt sich das P eins sich halt vor allem in Bayern tummelt. So also in Bayern sind tatsächlich ja
dass sechzig Prozent der Fälle äh aufgetreten äh und hier,
zweihundertsiebenundfünfzig Fälle und dann kommt noch Baden-Württemberg mit sechzig Fällen und
dass viel größere Nordrhein-Westfalen hatte bislang nur achtzehn Fälle und alle anderen Bundesländer sind da einstellig.
Also äh jetzt bei den Zahlen ist die nackten Zahlen, die festgestellt wurden, nicht die tatsächliche Zahl der der Fälle. Ja, während die
die eins drei fünf eins die ist halt im Saarland extrem verbreitet.
Das ist sehr krass äh so, also im Saarland genauso viel wie in Bayern oder Baden-Württemberg und Saarland ist ja so ziemlich die die kleinste
Einheit an Bundesländern, wenn man jetzt nicht auf Stadtstarten geht, wobei selbst ich meine, ich glaube, Berlin ist drei Saarland oder so. Äh wir haben früher mal alles in Saarland gemessen, wo.
Machen wir bestimmt demnächst auch wieder, wenn wir erstmal die passenden Infektionszahlen da gemeldet bekommen, wenn die erstmal alles aufmachen.
Also das Saarland ist sowieso äh so ein so ein Ding. Ich meine, das ist winzig. Äh da leben kaum Leute
und ähm ja da ist nix so richtig und ähm das Parlament ist auch winzig. Da sitzen grad mal fünfzig Leute drin und ist alles so ein bisschen alles sehr muckelig.
Und ja, ich hatte mir ein bisschen.
Auch äh Flagg eingefangen mit meinem Tweet, wo ich meinte, müsste doch vielleicht angesichts des Versagens der Bundesländer doch mal schauen, ob man nicht vielleicht ge.
Zusammenlegt.
Gesundheit und nicht erstens Gesundheit und Bildung an den Bund gibt und außerdem die Zahl der Bundesländer einfach mal halbiert. Ähm das äh Herr Sting und da wir Herr Saarland halt voll der Kandidat
weil ja.
Bremen ist kleiner, ne? Muss man mal dazu sagen, ne? Also Bremen ist so ein halbes Saarland.
Ist nochmal so eine spezielle Geschichte äh so, dass es dann immer, dass du dann halt auch mehr Konfliktlinien, wenn du dann so einen Stadtstart mit dem Umland
zusammenpackst, da gibt's halt die klassische,
Konfliktlinie in der Politik zwischen Stadt und Land so wie zwischen Arbeit und Kapital die andere Konfliktlinie und noch so ein paar andere äh und deshalb
Das ist also,
dass es halt schwieriger ähm so da wie gesagt einen Stadtstaat und einen ländlichen Staat zusammenzubringen, weil es da doch gewisse Unterschiede gi,
auch wo der Fokus der Politik jeweils liegt. Aber ja.
Weiß ich nicht gut, wird eh nicht passieren, also die Gefahr besteht jetzt nicht, also keine liebe Saarländer jetzt nicht in Panik ausbrechen und ihr seid auch alle ganz nette Leute und ich mag ich das also Saarland ist halt schon ja
guter Wein und irgendwie gutes Essen und so, was alles.
Schöne Varianten auch.
Viel Korruption allerdings so aber ja Korruption kann auch gemütlich sein so.
Ja. So jetzt wo waren wir erst so bei den Varianten.
Wir waren bei den Varianten und ich denke, wir können jetzt äh abschließend sagen, also B eins eins sieben ist quasi überall, da wo es noch nicht ist, kommt's demnächst hin. P eins und äh also Brasilien und Südafrika
versucht sich irgendwie mit einzubringen, kommt aber ein B eins eins sieben offenbar nicht so ohne Weiteres vorbei und
dass es die Situation, in der wir uns befinden. Wir haben insgesamt steigende Zahlen. Das Saarland ist noch eine Ausnahme, aber auch nur gerade soeben und liegt selber auch noch nicht in einem gesunden Bereich und von daher,
gehen wir davon aus, die Zahlen werden weiter steigen und sie werden unter Umständen auch nochmal ein bisschen mehr Dynamik erfahren,
besondere, wenn halt fleißig weitergelockert wird und,
wie sich Ostern konkret auswirkt. Muss man auch mal sehen, aber nachdem ja dann irgendwie auch die Kirchen nicht dazu gebracht werden konnten, ihre äh Gottesdienste einzustellen, denke ich mal. Wären wir da einfach nichts anderes sehen als steigende Zahlen.
Ja und in Berlin,
füllen sich auch schon wieder die Intensivstationen für alle, die jetzt irgendwie Zweifel daran haben, dass das mit dieser ganzen Zahlenerhebung, mit rechten Dingen.
Zugeht, so äh dass es dann letztlich an der definitive Indikator, weil ich meine Leute legen sich nicht zum Spaß ins Krankenhaus und auf die Intensivstation, ja? Das macht's keiner,
einfach nur, weil er, weil er bei ihm zu Hause langweilig ist äh oder so, sondern äh dass es dann halt also da das spricht auch eine klare Sprache.
Ja und da ist ja auch nun schon vor einigen Wochen ordentlich gewarnt worden, dass dass das alles passieren wird und jetzt passiert's halt sind alle wieder so ich.
Und jetzt warten wir halt einfach nur drauf, bis die Zahlen hoch genug sind, dass äh ja die Politik dann.
Unter Zähne knirschen und sagen kann, oh mein Gott, die Zahlen sind jetzt so hoch, wir wollen ja nicht, aber.
Wir sind jetzt leider dazu gezwungen, weil sonst bricht wieder unser Gesundheitssystem zusammen. Also genau wieder diese blödsinnige Nummer, so der Versuch ähm die Pandemie.
Nach Intensivkapazitätsauslastung zu steuern, das war noch nie eine gute Idee so nach dem Motto, wir haben noch Platz auf den Intensivstationen.
Rein was so die Ministerpräsidenten dazu zu sagen haben mit wem soll ich anfangen mit Laschet oder mit Bouffier? Ich fang mal mit Laschet an.
Gorn. Mhm.
Oh mein.
Also Laschet ist noch irgendwie bei der saisonalen äh Geschichte angekommen so, also ungefähr noch ein Jahr äh zurück.
Also ja, Laschet ist also auch so ein ja eigentlich ja Saisonalitätsanhänger äh so oder die Anhänger einer.
Übertriebenen Saisonalität
so das findet man typischerweise eigentlich so im Corona verharmloser oder Corona Leugner oder wie auch immer.
Checker.
Man das nennt Lager und wenn man wusste jetzt gar nicht, dass äh Laschet dazugehört, aber ganz offensichtlich, also nach der Aussage würde ich sagen äh ja äh der Mann ist äh einfach ja.
Am falschen Platz, aber du ist nur äh Vorsitzender der CDU. Was kann passieren?
Und genau und potentieller Kandidat und Ministerpräsident des größten deutschen Bundeslandes. Ja.
Aber wir haben noch einen äh wir haben noch Herren Bouffier äh Ministerpräsident in Hessen.
Om
Was.
Das ist echt blütig.
So, ich ich sage mal, wo, wo tragen die ihren ihren ihren Kopf? Wo stecken die den?
Dass ich mein,
ja, es ist ja nicht so, ich meine, müsste ja jetzt nicht, nicht uns hören, sollten sie vielleicht äh einfach, dann wüssten sie halt halt auch Bescheid, aber ich diesmal war ja
alle also von Drosten über ähm ja äh eigentlich alle Epidemiologen.
Die sich dazu geäußert haben, die ich vernommen habe und ich höre auch durchaus mir mal diejenigen an, die da auch nicht so ganz ähm wenn man sich mit allen einig sind, aber diesmal Wahrheit.
Also so viel Einigkeit wie vor ja acht Wochen äh.
Länger ist es nämlich her als vor acht Wochen.
Also eigentlich auch im im November schon im im Oktober äh schon, aber also diesmal jedenfalls
war also so viel Einigkeit war noch nie, nachdem wir gesehen haben, wie sich das in England entwickelt hat, äh wie wir die Zahlen für B eins eins sieben hatten. Wir wussten.
Wie sich das hier bei uns verdoppelt und so, also das, das war ähm also da war's relativ einfach
so vorherzusagen, dass das in die Höhe gehen wird wieder und müsste jetzt mal spaßeshalber
nachhören oder beim äh Twitter nachgucken, wann äh wir das gesagt haben, aber äh ich glaube so ähm,
Wir waren da schon im Januar, das wäre irgendwie so April äh.
Den ja, also den den März oder April Logdown, äh den haben wir schon vor Monaten vorhergesa.
Mal unsere Vorhersagen mal als solche eintragen und irgendwie im Kalender markieren, aber vielleicht haben das ja andere für uns schon getan, keine.
Ich mein deswegen habe ich halt die ganze Zeit auch getwittert, weil da gibt's dann so ein Zeitstempel und das kann man nicht mehr editieren und da weiß man genau, bei Twitter, das ist sozusagen wie so ein kleiner Meinungsnotar äh.
Ja, aber du weißt ja, wie man das fakt, oder?
Was ne.
Na man twittert einfach jede beliebige äh Aussage und löscht danach die Tweets, die nicht gepasst haben.
Ja gut, ja. Okay.
Möglichst in irgendeinem Account, den man dann irgendwie zu dem Zeitpunkt noch auf privat gestellt hat.
Profis, Pavel, da bist du noch nicht ganz.
Nee, nee, ich äh mache das einfach so, weil ich will ja selber wissen, ob ich richtig gelegen habe oder nicht sonst.
Ja nichts. Also ich will ja.
Ich mach das ja nicht, um das Recht habenswillen, sondern um halt zu sehen, welche Fehler ich mache oder wo ich mich vielleicht verschätzt habe. Also das.
Klar, klar, klar, klar, klar. Na gut. Ähm ja, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was
kommt jetzt, ne? Jetzt können wir uns nochmal in Voraussagen üben und ich äh habe auch so ein paar Voraussagen von anderen jetzt nochmal gesehen, die das jetzt auch jüngst nochmal durch äh gerechnet haben. Da gab's zum Beispiel einen sehr ansehnlichen Blog
Beitrag von Dirk Pessler, der auch so zu diesen ganzen äh Hobbydurchrechnern äh gehört mit sehr viel Grafiken. Das fand ich ganz interessant.
Weil er eben auch äh ausgehend von der Situation von vor einer Woche, muss man dazu sagen, er wo noch nicht ganz klar war, dieser Osterunfall noch nicht so ganz klar war. Äh einfach mal so verschiedene Szenarien durchgerechnet hat. Ich will das jetzt hier nicht im Detail alles vortragen, aber im Kern hat er so Szenarien wie, wir machen jetzt gar nichts mehr
oder wir machen äh einen ähm wir gehen jetzt einfach auf die Situation vom ersten März zurück, also quasi vor den letzten Lockerungen
oder wir machen einen Lokdown wie im Februar und das machen wir dann irgendwie ab April oder wir machen's vielleicht jetzt schon äh ab dieser Woche.
Und egal was man da irgendwie ausrechnet, es ist alles irgendwie schlimm. Also die Spannbreite,
geht von äh na ja von so anderthalb Millionen neu infizierten bis sech
Millionen neu infizierten von hundertfünfzig Longkowit-Fällen, äh hundertfünfzigtausend Long-Kowit-Fällen bis sechshunderttausend Long-Kowit-Fällen und äh von äh ähm
einundzwanzigtausend Todesfällen bis fünfundfünfzigtausend Todesfällen. Also verschiedene Kombinationen von
weitermachen oder äh also entweder nichts tun oder im im besten Fall so weitermachen wie vorher.
Würde man jetzt so ein Full-Look-Down machen wie man ihn vor einem Jahr hat,
Was wir ja eigentlich schon längere Zeit hier auch gefordert haben, weil's eigentlich der der einzige war, der wirklich effektiv war, der einzige, der es geschafft hat, mal einen R unter null Komma sieben zu bringen
ja, der relativ schnell läuft
dann könnte man diese dritte Welle noch äh abfedern und hätte halt nur sechshundertsechzigtausend äh Neuinfektionen und dreizehntausend Tote und vor allem im Gegensatz zu den anderen Modellen, die alle so im Juli oder August enden, hätte man hier schon,
Anfang Juni also Ende Mai, Anfang Juni
sehr niedrige Institzen und würde es damit sozusagen runterkämpfen. Also soweit sind wir schon, dass wenn wir jetzt.
Heute quasi mit Veröffentlichung dieser Sendung
in diesen totalen Lokdown mit, es fahren keine Autos mehr auf den Straßen, die Läden haben zu die Autoindustrie stellt ihre Produktion ein und so weiter, also so richtig Hardcore Lokdown äh in der im deutschen Flavor, ja, was ja im internationalen Vergleich immer noch nicht,
dem Vergleich standhält, ne? Aber sozusagen, so das, was wir schon mal kennengelernt haben, selbst dann.
Würden wir das Infektionsgeschehen erst im Juni wieder dahin bringen, wo wir's im letzten Jahr dann äh im Mai gebracht haben? Ja, das ist so der Ausblick und.
Es ist natürlich auch klar, das wird jetzt nicht geschehen. Weil es ist, das haben wir ja gesehen, die ganzen Diskussionen gehen nicht in die richtige Richtung.
Eher die.
Sozusagen die Nachricht des Tages wäre vielleicht auch dann als Sendungs äh Titelvorschlag sonst hast bisher hast du das ja immer super gemacht,
Aber wie wär's mit Kovit dauert dieses Jahr länger?
Ja
Also äh ich meine letztes Jahr, ja, haben wir ja, wie gesagt, mit richtigen Logdown, haben wir's dann ja im Prinzip im im Mai.
Waren die Zahlen unten, da konnten wir, wir konnten, glaube ich, schon immer
die ersten Ende April habe ich die ersten Lockerungen anfangen Mai machen und im Juni waren wir dann durch. Das ist dieses Jahr nicht zu erwarten. Also eigentlich fragte gestern jemanden einen Wirt,
der jetzt auch seit einem Jahr seine Kneipe geschlossen hat, so ähm wie es denn ja was ich denn glauben würde, äh wann er denn den Laden aufmachen kann, habe ich ihm gesagt, so ja, September
Oktober wahrscheinlich so, also.
Mit halbwegs normalen Betrieb. So Restaurants, Gastronomie werden wir schon wahrscheinlich früher äh einfach sehen, so Außengastronomie und so, aber ähm ja
also es wird nicht so gut laufen wie letztes Jahr, das ist schon mal klar, weil ähm ja also.
Glaubt nicht, dass das so schnell vorbei ist.
Wobei man muss jetzt ein bisschen abwägen mit was was sollte nicht passieren und was wird passieren? Ich kann mir halt immer
mein meine Wahrnehmung dieser ganzen Situation
ist und ich habe mich ja genauso wie du dann auch äh nach dieser ganzen Osterlokdown Posse irgendwie auch in so so äh Twittereien verstiegen und einfach mal kräftig ausatmen müssen, um's einfach noch ertragen zu können. Aber,
Ich hab einfach so den Eindruck die Politik hat aufgegeben. Also es ist sie haben aufgegeben.
Diese Situation noch zu managen. Es ist einfach, es gibt kein Willen, irgendwas noch,
dagegen zu tun, sondern sie wollen einfach irgendwie weiterleben, auch wenn bei diesem Weiterleben.
Weiter gestorben wird. So ist es einfach. Man hat.
Aufgegeben jetzt noch in irgendeiner Form. Also es hat seine ganze Bedrohung verloren. So die ganzen Toten, das war vor einem Jahr
Oh Gott, jetzt sterben schon so und so viele Leute. Mit der zweiten Welle haben wir das irgendwie alles weggeräumt. Und jetzt ist es so, ach was, wie jetzt nochmal was dagegen machen so, aber jetzt ist auch Sommer. Äh das das kann können wir nicht mehr äh zumuten und wir müssen doch die Wirtschaft und überhaupt und deswegen wird jetzt einfach
so weitergehen und dann werden die Biergärten wieder offen haben. So, nur werden halt parallel die Leute das ausbaden müssen, die
Im Krankenhaus arbeiten, die im Gesundheitssystem äh arbeiten und es müssen vor allem die Leute ausbaden, die halt sterben und die,
Angehörige verlieren und die die krank werden und dann einfach äh diese Langzeitfolgen äh erdulden müssen, die einfach kein kein Spaß sind. Und das wird
einfach von dieser Gesellschaft nicht mehr honoriert, dass dass man das verhindern will, weil für alle der Preis zu hoch ist, nämlich der Preis wäre was zu tun.
Ne und die ja und die fünfzigtausend Toten sind ähm ja zumindest sofern es keine Angehörigen waren,
also aus der zweiten Welle sind vergessen, niemand ist dafür zur Rechenschaft äh gezogen worden, weil
Großteil war, war vermeidbar so. Äh ist nicht vermieden worden und äh ja ist einmal gut gegangen. Jetzt können wir mal gucken.
Wie weit wir diesmal kommen gehen und ja bei den Alten, wenn man sich das wären jetzt schon nicht mehr so viele werden, nur.
Ich sehe jetzt zwei mögliche Szenarien. Das Wahrscheinlichere ist und da setze ich dann schon doch noch ein bisschen auf die große Gruppe der Vernünftigen,
Die ja größer ist definitiv als die Politik.
Glaubt oder sich sich einbildet. Ich meine äh Politikermacher wie gesagt jetzt gerade Politik hauptsächlich für die Deppen, ja? Und nicht äh und für Idioten und nicht für vernünftige Leute.
Die werden im Stich gelassen und ja äh aber sag mal ich denke, dass diese
diese vernünftigen
Das sind die Leute, die selber sich Zahlen angucken und selber eine Maske aufsetzen äh wenn die Zahlen hoch sind oder sie sich in gefährliche Situationen begeben, die
den braucht man äh nicht so viele Vorschriften zu machen. So.
Auf die setze ich so ein bisschen meine Hoffnung, äh dass die halt auch äh einfach von sich aus reagieren können, wobei das Problem ist, dass die wahrscheinlich alle sowieso schon super vorsichtig sind. Jetzt.
Ähm lässt man jetzt laufen
dann ja es ist alles möglich, dann können wir auch so tschechische Institenzen schaffen mit irgendwie bis tausend. So, das ist alles alles drin. Äh aber
so wie gesagt, da ich denke, dass die Leute hier nicht sich komplett
gehen lassen werden und auch die Politik, die dann doch, ja, quasi wir in diesen mehr oder weniger Dauerlock
down verharren werden oder ja ist ja kein richtiger Lokdown, aber wenn's mal
in diesem aktuellen Maßnahmenbündel mehr oder weniger verharren werden, sodass es eben auch nicht.
Unkontrolliert wächst und äh dann vielleicht mit zusammen mit ein bisschen Saisonalität denke ich wird, wenn wir irgendwo zwischen zwei bis dreihundert hoffentlich im Piek land.
Und äh ja und ich fürchte nur, das wird sich aber genau deswegen auch wieder wieder hinziehen. Aber.
Wenn jetzt noch mehr Saarlands daher kommen,
äh und noch mehr Modellregionen, äh wo man äh alles aufmacht und mal ausprobiert, was denn so passiert, wenn man alles aufmacht, weil äh es,
wissen wir ja nicht, dass konnte ja keiner ahnen, äh dass äh wenn wir jetzt alles aufmachen, die Zahlen so schnell äh wieder nach oben gehen. Also dabei haben wir doch so viele Vorsichtsmaßnahmen äh.
Skinner und der Sommer, ja. Genau. Ja.
Dann ist ja auch egal, was die Leute vor acht Wochen gesagt haben.
Und vor allem ist auch im März ist halt voll Sommer, ja? Es ist ave, dieser Typ. So könnte ich nur schlagen einfach. Ja, schlimm.
Ich bitte ihn nicht mit einem nassen Waschlappen einfach links und rechts platsch, platsch, Platsch.
Weil mir gerade die Schnelltests ein, aber ähm.
Kommen wir gleich noch zu ähm.
OK wir können dann den Bereich mit den Voraussagen jetzt mal abschließen also wir können's jetzt nicht auf 'ne werden's jetzt auch hier offen nicht auf eine Zahl bringen aber das Ding ist halt einfach es wird weiterlaufen.
Also Dimensionsmäßig nur für den Hinterkopf so, die zweite Welle waren zwei Millionen Infektionen und fünfzigtausend Tote so, wenn man sich Hausnummern mäß,
ja ähm und die Prognosen jetzt sehen bisschen besser aus, so also zumindest die die mittleren ähm,
dort in dem Szenario wegen halt teilweise Impfquote und anderen äh Dingen, aber
Das sind so die Dimensionen, von denen wir grundsätzlich reden, ja? Nochmal zwei Millionen Infektionen und nochmal fünfzigtausend äh Tote, wobei hoffentlich.
Bisschen weniger durch die Impf.
Berg ein bisschen schmaler wird, wird wahrscheinlich genauso hoch, also größenordnungsmäßig, vielleicht schaffen wir halt auch die Hälfte somit nur eine Million neue Infektionen und fünfundzwanzigtausend Tote. Ähm die nächste Welle
Aber Garantien gibt's nicht. Also es ist auch locker äh drin, dass wir
Also wir wir können auch das Impfen
noch wieder was heißt überholen. Ähm also im Moment liegt, liegt es Virus ja noch deutlich vorne
bei Langen, was Immunisierung angeht
und wenn, wenn wir laufen lassen, wenn man so richtig laufen lassen, dann können wir auch, kriegen wir auch noch zehn Millionen Infektionen hin und.
Zweihunderttausend Tote.
Liegt nicht vorne. Wir wir impfen mehr pro Tag als.
Die Geschwindigkeit, ja, aber sozusagen der Stand, wie viele des Virus schon erreicht hat und wie viele äh Impfungen äh schon verabreicht.
Worden äh so, ja, dass das meinte ich halt und ähm ja weil.
Schaue doch einfach mal auf die Impfung, dass wir das auch nochmal äh äh erwähnt haben. Das Ding ist.
Impffunder von Berlin.
Das genau das bevor wir auf das Impfwunder von Berlin äh eingehen, schauen wir einfach mal, also,
Ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt, die gute Nachricht ist, also die Nachricht ist, die Nachricht ist, dass wir jetzt zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung erst geimpft haben.
Und irgendwie klingt es ja schön, ne? Bloß dann denkt man mal kurz drüber nach und sagt ja, okay, seit wann impfen denn jetzt? Ah ja, seit drei Monaten, ziemlich genau.
Das heißt, wir haben's jetzt in drei Monaten geschafft, zehn Prozent der Bevölkerung zu verimpfen.
Ja, also nach dreist nach siebenundzwanzig Monate bei dem Tempo, wenn sich das nicht steigert. Das heißt.
Ja, gut, also auf auf hundert Prozent werden wir ja eh nie kommen. Ja,
Aber ähm wir wollten ja zumindest mal so bei sechzig oder siebzig Prozent äh liegen. So und wenn wir halt jetzt so für die nächsten sechzig Prozent
dann auch sechs Mal drei Monate brauchen mh ja das das dauert einfach alles zu lang.
So wird es auch nicht kommen. Wir werden mehr Impfstoff
erhalten und wir werden eine Steigerung sehen, aber ich hab mir mal angeschaut welche Zusagen denn jetzt existieren und ich werd auch gleich nochmal auf die Astra Cineca Situation gesondert eingehen.
Dann ist meiner Meinung nach jetzt im April bestenfalls mit einer Verdoppelung zu rechnen.
Ja, also wir werden da nicht sehr viel mehr als doppelt so viele Impfungen sehen mit ein bisschen Glück vielleicht.
Noch etwas mehr als ein Faktor zwei, aber so ein Faktor drei würde mich extrem überraschen und ein Faktor vier bis fünf ist eigentlich das, was wir bräuchten.
Konkret heißt das, wir haben jetzt so in dieser Woche ähm also jetzt gestern, sind wir bei zweihundertneunundsiebzigtausend Impfungen gewesen, das ist so in etwa auch so das, was so diese Woche seit Montag so lief
Das heißt so im Schnitt sind wir dann, wenn das Wochenende wieder runter geht, womit äh zu rechnen ist. Ja.
Immer noch schlechter als in der Woche davor, das heißt, wir haben uns auch von diesem Asta Cineca Schock noch nicht so richtig erholt. Seitdem Astra Zineka für ein paar Tage ausgesetzt wurde, ist es nie wieder so angelaufen und es hat nicht diese Steigerung erfahren
die wir gerne gesehen hätten. Wie sehr sich das jetzt noch schnell wieder ausgleichen kann, weiß ich nicht, aber derzeit sieht's halt so aus.
Und ich sag mal wenn man so mit.
Anführungszeichen normalen Leuten auf der Straße redet oder aus dem ähm bekannten
Kreis, die so jetzt das alles nicht täglich verfolgen, sondern nur so bisschen was, was halt so in den Medien
los ist äh und
da hat sich halt bei vielen auch die Meinung verfestigt, die wollen kein Astra Senika. Die wollen das gute Biontech
so und meinten, dann warten sie lieber, bis sie halt Bayern Tech kriegen, ja. Was natürlich total Quatsch ist. So, um das auch gleich äh zu sagen
ähm außer in ganz besonderen Ausnahmefällen, so sollte man ja äh oder.
Nun so, ich würde äh auch äh sofort äh Astra-Senika nehmen, äh wenn es denn für mich verfügbar wäre
und was wir jetzt auch ja im im letzten Clubhaus äh glaube ich.
Wo die Lena, die sie glaube ich, ne. Äh.
Helga, äh Elga, genau. Äh fand ich auch nochmal äh äh ganz interessant, dass sie so bestätigte, was auch mein Eindruck.
Warf äh man so mit Leuten redet, dass nämlich Astra Sinica,
die größeren Reaktionen bei der Erstimpfung macht
und während Bayerntech so bei der Zweitimpfung mehr reinhaut. Da aber die meisten Leute erstmal nur die Erstimpfung haben, sie sieht es halt erstmal so aus wie upsi.
Irgendwie liegen ja mehr Leute mit Astra Sinika flach als mit Bayerntech Faiser. So.
Und ja gibt jetzt zunehmend mehr Leute in meinem Bekanntenkreis, die äh jetzt schon geimpft sind und die habe ich natürlich dann immer persönlich gefragt und wie war's so, weil
äh ja aus erster Hand ist halt halt äh immer gut und da war jetzt niemand, der ja ähm also auch mit äh oder eine Person mit, die mit Bayern Tech Faiser äh geimpft,
wurde, hat daneben auch ja ziemlich
empfindliches Gefühl an der Einstichstelle, also wenn halt Schlafprobleme und so, weil äh keine Ahnung, der Abend hart weh und Müdigkeit
So und das war ja das gute Bayerntech Faiser, also es ist jetzt aber jetzt auch nichts was nicht zu erwarten äh gewesen wäre, ja.
Ja, Management. Ich meine, die die Ängste sind natürlich nachvollziehbar, aber sie sind eben noch noch lange nicht ähm.
Durch durch die Realität irgendwie gedeckt. Wir hatten das ja jetzt letzte Woche schon diskutiert, was da gerade alles äh rund um als Astrasinica noch erforscht wird. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht wieder aufgreifen
nur denke ich mal, werden wir da noch ein paar Wochen brauchen, bis wir da so richtige Klarheit haben, aber es spricht halt auch sehr viel dafür.
Dass es hier keine ursächlichen Zusammenhang gibt, ja, sondern das ist eher was mit der Infektion, mit der ähm Reakt, mit der Immunreaktion als solches äh auftritt, dass also hier Leute Probleme haben, die.
Vielleicht mit jedem Impfstoff und vielleicht auch mit äh der Infektion, mit dem Virus selbst entsprechende Probleme gelaufen wären, ne.
Sage ich jetzt nicht, ist so, ich sage nur, das kann genauso gut noch sein, ja, dass das äh am Ende bei rauskommt. Eine
Kerninformationen, die ihr vielleicht an dieser Stelle einfach nochmal mit nach Hause nehmen solltet, weil das immer mit diesen ganzen Zahlen und was man alles irgendwie erklärt, schnell immer wieder äh weggeht
Diese ganze Debatte und das hören wir, das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen auch so ein Auslöser, ne, dass die Leute sagen, ja, nee, ich will ja das mit dem fünfundneunzig Prozent Wirkung haben.
Und nicht das mit den siebenundsechzig Prozent oder zweiundsiebzig Prozent oder welche Zahl auch immer gerade durch den Raum fliegt.
Diese Wirksamkeit. Und ich finde, das ist auch ein Kardinalfehler, der der mh Öffentlichkeitskommunikation an der Stelle. Ich glaube, das ist wieder so ein Problem. Dadurch, dass.
Meldungen aus dem medizinischen Bereich in in Studien oder jetzt eben auch in den Zahlen, die bei der Zulassung der Impfstoffe vorgelegt werden. So schnell in die Öffentlichkeit geraten und dort auch,
großem Interesse aufgenommen werden, was ja auch absolut nachvollziehbar ist, ja? Werden sie aber oft falsch verstanden, weil man nicht wirklich genau versteht
was exakt das bezeichnet, weil dieses der und der Impfstoff hat nur zweiundsiebzig Prozent Wirksamkeit gezeigt. Bei den Leuten halt sagt oh Gott
ich könnte zu den achtundzwanzig Prozent Gehörden, die dann sterben.
Das ist sozusagen das, was im Kopf so abgeht, ne? Bei mir wirkt der dann vielleicht gar nicht. Aber das ist nicht das Ding, sondern was man da gemessen hat ist das,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit da irgendwie einen schlechten äh äh eine schlechte Wirkung zu haben entsprechend abgesenkt ist. Vergesst diese ganze Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung, merkt euch einfach nur zwei Sachen,
erstens alle Impfstoffe einschließlich Astra Senika.
Alle haben sowohl in den Trails als auch jetzt in der Phase vier Studien in der Beobachtung des äh ähm.
Impfens.
Das das Impfens, der das Ausrollen, der der Impfkampagne, ja, zu hundert Prozent vor einem tödlichen Verlauf der Kowit-Krankheit geführt und zu hundert Prozent vor schweren Verläufen.
Und das ist das, was wir, was wir eigentlich befürchten. Ja, also diese Impfstoffe schützen wirklich umfänglich vor dem, was wir eigentlich alle.
Befürchten, was mit uns passieren kann durch eine Infektion. Und das ist wirklich die, die sehr, sehr, sehr gute Nachricht. Ja, jetzt gibt's Leute, die sind gestorben nach einer Impfung,
Abgesehen davon, dass Leute auch sonst gestorben wären, ja? Kann es sein,
dass eben diese Immunreaktion bei manchen Leuten zu Problemen führt. Aber die Leute sind nicht an der Krankheit gestorben
und das ist halt äh die eigentliche Botschaft. Ich habe auch nochmal einen kleinen YouTube-Film äh verlinkt, wo das auch nochmal schön äh schlüssig erläutert wird, diese Unterschiede. Äh den könnt ihr euch schnappen und.
Weiterleiten.
Plus, was ich noch so ein ganz interessantes Detail
fand, äh, was mir vorher auch nicht so ganz klar war, was ich da auch auf Klapphaus erfahren äh habe, dann das Jahr Astra Sinnika,
dass das eben Forscher sind, dass das halt von der Uni kommt ähm so und dass sich dann eben.
Äh
aber ja auch die Firmen, die die Firma Astra Sinika äh dass die sich dann sehr auf die Wissenschaftler verlassen haben auch bei der Kommunikation und die haben
halt aus,
anderen Motivationen heraus dann ein bisschen das mit den Studien etwas ungeschickt gehandelt, weil sie halt drei verschiedene Studien gemacht haben in drei verschiedenen Ländern und daraus drei verschiedene Veröffentlichungen gemacht haben,
statt, die das halt Profis machen.
Sagen die Triiles erstens gleich designen alle drei und dann die Zahlen alle zusammenwerfen.
Und dann äh halt auf dieser Basis äh dann die Prozentwerte.
Berechnen und da ergab sich dann halt ganz schnell dann auch als Astra Seneka äh das gemacht hat, hatten sie dann,
plötzlich auch deutlich bessere,
Zahlen. Aber äh da waren dann irgendwie die sechzig oder siebzig Prozent waren dann halt erstmal in der Welt.
Schon mal und sagen, dass das halt auch so eine Lehre vielleicht daraus für angehende Impfstoffhersteller
so das Ganze ist jetzt keine rein wissenschaftliche Veranstaltung sondern es geht dabei um ein Produk.
Was man zulassen möchte und auch ein Produkt
dass äh natürlich auch ein möglichst tadellosen Ruf haben sollte, ohne dass man jetzt was verschweigen müsste, aber wenn man halt, wie gesagt, dann drei verschiedene Studien äh macht
und äh so manche davon aufgrund geringer Zahlen äh oder aufgrund besonderer lokaler Verhältnisse wie in Brasilien.
Dann halt abweichende Werte äh liefern. Ähm die nicht so schön aussehen, ja,
das ist halt für so ein Produkt oder für seinen Ruf dann dann auch nicht gut. Leider.
Ja und diese Wirksamkeitsstudien sind auch nicht ohne weiteres vergleichbar. Das muss man auch nochmal dazu sagen. Also sowohl moderner als auch Bayern Tech hatte quasi
deren Prials waren zu einem Zeitpunkt sowohl in den USA ähm als auch in äh Europa waren, war das sozusagen.
Da gingen die Pandemie
relativ soft ab im Vergleich zu dem, ne? Also es war nicht in der ersten Welle, es war nicht in der zweiten Welle. Während jetzt zum Beispiel Johnson und Johnson halt mitten in der zweiten Welle irgendwie
getestet wird. Das wird Auswirkungen haben. Am Ende wird man trotzdem daraus ablesen können.
Ob diese Impfstoffe wirksam sind und bei Johnson Johnson ist das ja auch der Fall.
Aber man sollte darauf nicht zu viel geben, es sei denn, man hat wirklich vollständig zu hundert Prozent genau verstanden, was diese Zahlen bedeuten. Wie gesagt, am Ende nimmt nur alles mit.
Diese Impfstoffe helfen, verhindern zu hundert Prozent Tod und äh verhindern zu hundert Prozent schwere Verläufe und das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr gute Nachricht und deswegen sollte man sich impfen lassen,
auch mit Astra Senika. Auch mit allem anderen, was da noch raus.
Und selbst wenn man nicht so tief in die Zahlen äh reingehen will, also wo ich persönlich meine Überzeugung ähm halt rausziehe, so ich weiß halt, dass in England
über zehn Millionen Leute mit Astra Senika geimpft worden sind. Ja und da gab es nicht wirklich große Auffälligkeiten. Äh.
So also war jetzt größenordnungsmäßig von Biontech Faiser.
Kein Unterschied bei berichteten
Äh ja Krankheiten oder Erkrankungen in zeitlichen Zusammenhang mit der Impfung. So da sind also keine besonderen Häufungen festgestellt worden
ähm sagt, es gibt halt,
eine etwas andere Verteilung. Was berichtet wurde zwischen den verschiedenen Impfstoffen, aber ansonsten so in der Summe.
Ja
Alles so das Gleich.
Das halt gleich und wie gesagt und und es wurden halt, wenn ich meine, wenn mit irgendwas zehn Millionen Leute geimpft worden sind und die das sind
nicht reihenweise Leute bei krank geworden oder tot umgefallen äh so dann würde ich sagen äh einfach das sicher ne.
Und es kommt noch dazu
das hatten wir ja hier auch schon diskutiert und dann können wir diesen Bereich vielleicht auch erstmal abschließen äh Untersuchungen aus Schottland oder überhaupt aus Großbritannien haben ja dann auch noch gezeigt, dass mit Astra Senika sogar diese Hospitalisierung, also die Krankenhauseinweisung bei,
Erkrankung noch mehr zurückgegangen ist als bei Biotech. Also es gibt sehr gute Indikationen dafür, dass äh alle Impfstoffe im Prinzi
mehr oder weniger gleichwirksam sind, weil sie auch äh letzten Endes alle auf das selbe Prinzip setzen, ja? Also all diese Impfstoffe machen eigentlich
exakt genau das Gleiche. Spike Protein vom Körper produzieren lassen. Wie das angestoßen wird.
Unterscheidet sich ein bisschen, weil ein anderer Eintrittsvektor gewählt wird, ja? Beim einen sind's kleine Fettkügelchen, die direk
die RNA in eure Zelle plumpsen lassen bei dem anderen wird es irgendwie in so ein äh Virus, der einem nicht schaden kann, rein äh geworfen und dann läuft das so seinen normalen Weg durch die
Zelle über den Zellkern, aber am Ende passiert immer dasselbe,
Körper fängt an, Spike Proteine zu erzeugen, woraufhin die Immunreaktion einsetzt und wenn dann der blöde Virus kommt, dann kennen wir den schon und dann wird er einfach rausgeschmissen.
Wir wollen dich nicht hier drin haben. Und es funktioniert.
Genau, mit Antikörpern zugekleistert.
Unter anderem, nicht nur, aber auch unten Teezellen und hast du nicht gesehen,
Jetzt müssen wir aber noch von dem von dem Impfwunder aus Berlin äh berichten. Was wir nämlich noch nicht ganz verstehen, weil das kam heute erst raus und lässt noch so ein bisschen Fragezeichen zurück
Ähm es gibt einen Lagebericht, in dem halt die Berliner Zahlen gemeldet werden. Ansonsten ist Berlin nicht so geil, im Melden von Zahlen, zumindest nicht, was äh Impfungsmeldungen ans RKI betrifft. Und da ist was
komisches passiert und zwar gestern also Donnerstag der fünfundzwanzigste März hat.
Angeblich Berlin vierzigtausend Impfungen durchgeführt mit Astra Sinika.
Gestern und ich glaub's irgendwie noch nicht so richtig.
Hast du deine Erklärung dafür? Handelt es sich hierbei um dieses Modellsystem mit den Hausärzten,
Oder sind das die nachgemeldeten Astra-Senika äh Impfungen der letzten Tage, die sie nachgeholt haben, aber auch das erklärt ja nicht diese unglaublich.
Zahl, ja genau.
Werden's zu viel, also selbst wenn man die ausgefallenen Astra-Senika-Impfungen äh aus der Woche aufeinander stapeln würde.
Dann ja wer dem nicht so, also entweder ist es wurde irgendwie eine Sonder.
Kampagne durchgezogen, um die ganzen Leute nachzuimpfen und in dem Zuge hat man dann vielleicht dann auch noch mehr
reingeworfen, vielleicht gab's irgendwie eine Einmalieferung, also Erklärung habe ich nicht, das äh ich wissen wir in der nächsten Sendung dann mehr, vielleicht klärt sich das ja noch auf, ob das ob das real ist, ob,
da irgendwie nur nachgemeldet wurde oder hm ob das ein Zahlenfehler, Meldefehler ist. Wir wissen's nicht,
aber.
Hätte man schon mal irgendwie auch mal erklären können, äh vielleicht okay, vielleicht wurde es auch schon erklärt, ähm keine Ahnung, dann haben wir es aber noch nicht mitbekommen.
Zum Zeitpunkt des Redaktionsschlusses von UKW Korona Wiekli äh lag diese Information uns leider noch nicht vor,
oder wir waren zu faul, sie rauszusuchen. Eins von beiden. Irgendwas ist ja immer.
Gut, dann äh bleiben wir aber nochmal kurz bei äh Astra Sinika. Ich hatte das letzte Woche ja schon mal angesprochen. Es gibt da ja gerade die äh die Werkswars, wie ich sie genannt habe. Die Astra Sinica Wex Wars.
Und ich habe immer noch kein vollständiges Bild, aber es gab nun die Meldung, dass in ähm.
Italien hat mir das letzte Woche eigentlich schon irgendwie mit diesen ich glaube das war das war noch in dieser Woche, ne? Also in Italien seien,
äh neunundzwanzig Millionen Dosen, Astra Senika.
Stoff gefunden worden. In einem Lager, von wo aus es dann versendet werden soll.
Und jetzt gibt es sehr viel Streit darum und sehr viel unterschiedliche Behauptungen und ehrlich gesagt ich bin nicht bereit mich auch nur irgendeinem der beiden Lager hier äh komplett zu verschreiben. Auf jeden Fall gibt's sehr viel Streit da drum,
Wohin denn nun diese Dosen hätten eigentlich gehen sollen? Wäre sozusagen äh ureigener Empfänger dieser Dosen sind und warum die da so großen Mengen vorlagen und da keiner was von wusste
Dazu muss man wissen, Astrasinica wird, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, in der EU produziert in Holland und in Italien.
Und das ist halt teilweise für den europäischen Markt, teilweise ist es für Großbritannien
teilweise gehen äh diese Impfstoffe allerdings auch an diese Kowaks Initiative. Hatte ich hier schon mal erwähnt, Kowax ist quasi so dieser
Impfspendenpool, wo man Geld oder äh Impfdosen reinwerfen kann, damit die irgendwie Trittweltländern zugute kommen.
Daraufhin hat sich dann der Streit, der ohnehin schon so schwelte zwischen Großbritannien, Astra Senika und EU ähm weiter entzündet, also bisher war der Streit ja eigentlich eher der, Astra Senika hat,
einen Vertrag abgeschlossen mit der EU über die Lieferung von zweihundertzwanzig Millionen.
Impfdosen. In diesem Quartal. Hat dann aber zurückgezogen, hat gesagt, ja nee äh kriegen wir nicht hin, gibt nur neunzig Millionen.
Bisher ausgeliefert wurden, weiß mich neunzehn oder neunundzwanzig Millionen. Jetzt komme ich mit den Zahlen gerade durcheinander. Also auf jeden Fall zu wenig.
Die EU wird jetzt so langsam ein bisschen zickig
weil sie halt sieht, dass irgendwie UK äh wunderbar vorankommt und sehr viel mit Astra Senika verimpft, selber aber noch nicht mal ansatzweise das, was äh in den Verträgen ausgehandelt war
bekommt und das mit Impfstoffen, die auch noch in der EU produziert werden. So, kann man sich schon vorstellen, dass das nicht so geil ankommt, ne?
Dann kam natürlich gleich die UK an hier, Boris Johnson und meinte, ja, das hat ja alles seinen äh seine Ordnung, weil wir haben ja hier einen priorisierten Vertrag abgeschlossen und wir zahlen ja auch viel mehr Geld.
Äh wo die EU dann halt sagt, so, ja, uns doch egal, davon steht in unserem Vertrag nichts drin, so Vertrag ist Vertrag, der muss auch irgendwie eingehalten werden, ne,
So und wenn ihr irgendwie jetzt hier äh und das ist dann eine Astra Sinica äh gerichtet so. Äh wenn ihr hier jetzt irgendwie nicht spurt und mehr liefert, so dann dann verbieten wir euch komplett äh,
dass überhaupt noch äh exportieren zu dürfen. Was ein ziemlich harter Schritt ist, ne? Man muss dazu sagen.
Die EU, Indien und die USA, das sind so und China. Das sind so derzeit die Orte, wo überhaupt.
Impfstoff in nennenswerten Mengen produziert wird. Und.
In UK wird auch Astra Sinnika Impfstoff produziert, verlässt aber das Land nicht. Das heißt produziert bestimmte Mengen ausschließlich nur für den Eigenbedarf, exportiert.
Null Impfstoffdosen. Die USA produziert extrem viel im Stoff. Mittlerweile haben sie ja auch genug für sich selber, exportiert,
null Impfdosen davon. Jetzt gab's die Ankündigung, dass Kanada und ähm Kanad.
Und Mexiko auch was bekommen sollen und ich bin mir jetzt grad nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, da geht es dann tatsächlich auch um diese,
Astra Senikaimpfstoffe, die da ja lagern und noch überhaupt nicht zugelassen sind, aber so wenn sie dann zugelassen sind, dann gehen sie halt irgendwie dahin. Also da ist relativ wenig zu erwarten von den USA. Ich denke nicht, dass irgendwelche Impfstoffe von den USA nach Europa kommen werden
was sicherlich auch nochmal ein Streitpunkt wird, aber derzeit nicht so ganz hoch aufgelegt ist, ist ja auch klar, dass äh die USA jetzt diese Gelegenheit nutzen, weil jetzt haben sie diesen Surplus und sie haben sich's ja auch ordentlich vergrätzt
äh sowohl Mexiko als auch mit Kanada unter Trump, sodass sie jetzt genug Gründe haben
den mal irgendwie auch mal nett zu kommen. Dazu gibt's ja auch noch so ein bisschen diese Migrationskrise an der Grenze, die gerade in USA eine große Debatte ist und ist natürlich eine Top
Methode, die mexikanische Regierung dazu Kooperation zu bringen, wenn sie sagen, so, ja, aber wir haben ja auch noch Impfdosen. Das ist so die neue Währung.
Plus, dass die USA, äh, was das Thema Impfdiplomatie äh angeht halt da im Moment noch ein bisschen zurückliegen wahrscheinlich sogar gegenüber
allen anderen äh Regionen, also gegenüber EU, Russland und China, die sind da, ich sage mal deutlich freundlicher
gegenüber der Welt. Wobei es der EU bestimmt niemand dankt wieder am Ende, aber.
Nee, also ich meine es gilt im Übrigen, also sowohl ähm Indien als auch.
China als auch die EU exportieren ungefähr vierzig Prozent der im in den Ländern produzierten Impfstoffe ins Ausland.
Das ist das ist jetzt nichts, ne?
Aber dass du nicht auch die äh Nachricht da, dass Indien gerade den Export gestoppt hat.
Ja, das ist jetzt sozusagen die neue äh Debatte. Ich wollte jetzt nochmal ganz kurz nochmal dieses, die Situation zwischen der EU und UK äh hin und her bringen. Also.
Es hieß jetzt noch heute noch irgendwie, dass sie sich dann irgendwie geeinigt haben. Jetzt habe ich erst letztes wieder aufgeschnappt, dass es jetzt dann doch wieder offen ist und dass es jetzt durchaus sein kann, dass die EU einen Exportstopp äh verhängt. Ich glaube, sie werden sich am Ende
irgendwie einigen. Es geht hier einfach dadrum, um ein bisschen Druck auf Astra Sinnica zu machen, weil
Ich weiß nicht, was mit dem Laden kaputt ist, aber es läuft nicht alles rund. Ich meine, was die äh allgemeine Informationspolitik und das Handling dieser Krise äh also der Krise ihres eigenen Impfstoffs sozusagen in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung betrifft, sind sie jetzt eh nicht äh mit dem richtigen Fuß auf
aber halt, was jetzt auch noch so diese zugesagten Lieferungen betrifft, die sie nicht bedienen können gegenüber der EU. Das ist halt auch nicht besonders klug
Und Großbritannien hat ja eigentlich relativ schlechte Karten und man muss natürlich diese Auseinandersetzung auch im Kontext sehen der aktuellen
permanenten Auseinandersetzungen zwischen UK und EU äh im Rahmen der ganzen Brexitfolgen, weil das ist ja sozusagen auch noch etwas, was im Hintergrund.
Eine Rolle spielt und da wird natürlich dann wieder entsprechend gegen die EU gefeuert und wir sind ja eher in allem allen Schuld, ne? Also.
Aktueller Stand meines Wissens ist der, kann sein, dass es zu einem Export äh Stopp jetzt kommt,
das ist gerade die Aussage vom Binnenmarkt Kommissar,
Solange bis Astra Senika die Impfstoffe irgendwie freigibt. Gibt den Impfstoff frei und zwar sofort. Man muss dazu sagen.
Von diesen neunundzwanzig Millionen Dosen, die sie da jetzt gefunden haben. Sollten angeblich.
Die Hälfte irgendwie sowieso Richtung Kowax gehen. Das heißt, da fallen dann so im besten Fall dreizehn Millionen Impfstoffdosen ab. Astra Senika meint, das wäre sowieso für die EU gewesen.
Das wird uns jetzt nicht groß helfen. Das ist sagen wir mal nochmal eine separate Debatte. Es geht um ganz andere Mengen, die benötigt werden, um der EU wirklich mehr Impfpotential zu geben.
Ja
Und was sagst du? Äh nochmal vorhin, wie viele hatten sie versprochen, wie wie viel.
Hundertzwanzig Millionen hatten sie versprochen und das haben sie jetzt auf neunzig Millionen runtergekürzt.
Und die sind aber auch.
Nicht gekommen, das erinnert mich irgendwie an diese an diesen Verhandlungs äh Witz. Wie? Sie wollen zwanzig wo
fünfzehn zu viel sind. Äh ich gebe ihnen zehn. Hier haben sie drei. Äh.
Ja, so ähnlich klingt das. Genau und in Indien gehen die Zahlen auch gerade wieder kräftig nach oben. Und auch dort findet exakt dieselbe Debatte statt,
Ja, das heißt, sie liefern äh also sie produzieren da extrem viel Astrasinica, die haben zwar noch so einen zweiten zweiten Impfstoff, einen eigenen, aber von dem produzieren sie noch relativ wenig.
Und äh geben halt auch sehr viel an diese Kowaks Initiative an äh ab und liefern eben auch an äh andere Länder, also unter anderem an Brasilien, auch an UK, an Marokko, Saudi-Arabien
Und ja, aber jetzt wird da halt auch debattiert, weil eben die Infektionszahlen in Indien nach oben gehen und sie ihre Impfstoffkampagne
ihre Impfkampagne äh vorantreiben wollen, diskutieren sie halt jetzt auch einen Exportstopp von Astra Senika. Also es geht rund,
Äh auf der Welt und irgendwie ist immer Astra Senika dabei.
Mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Schalten sie auch das nächste nächste Woche ein. Wenn es heißt, was erlaube Astra Silika.
Ernst. Ja, war halt wirklich eine Telenovela, ja.
So, jetzt sollten wir aber nochmal ein anderes Thema anschneiden und zwar die Frage der
Schnelltests. Jetzt haben wir ja welche und äh teilweise sind sie auch verfügbar. Nicht unbedingt da, wo man sie äh braucht, zum Beispiel in der Schule.
Aber sie werden verkauft. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, sich selber schnell testen zu lassen. Manche haben Termine, manche nicht, manche brauchen auch keine Termine.
Andere Schuren und generell gibt es sehr viel Verwirrung darüber, was eigentlich Schnelltest jetzt zu dieser Situation tatsächlich positiv ist oder vielleicht auch Negatives, zur Gesamtsituation beitragen
Und auf der einen Seite haben wir eben diese Debatte mit ja, wir haben ja jetzt Schnelltest, jetzt können wir uns unsere Lockerungen auch erlauben,
Ne, so macht alles auf, macht Schulen auf, weil wir haben ja jetzt Schnelltest, das ist jetzt irgendwie Schnelltest ist so ist so der ähm,
zu der Reinigungsmarker, der, der irgendwie die, diese ganzen Kritzeleien auf dem Whiteboard irgendwie schnell mal äh äh wegmacht,
Ja, weil damit fangen wir ja alles auf, dann kann ja nichts mehr passieren. Alles ist sicher und,
Auf der anderen Seite gibt's natürlich auch so Zweifler, die sagen, hm es fühlen sich alle sicher und so weiter.
Ja, aber erstmal sagen, bevor wir dann in die vielleicht in die Details gehen, ähm kann man schon mal festhalten, ganz egal, welchen Schnelltest,
man benutzt oder überhaupt jeder Test, ein Testergebnis hat seine Gültigkeit für ungefähr zwölf Stunden.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt ankomme mit einmal die Woche testen, dann ist dieses Testergebnis vom ersten Tag nicht,
viel mehr Wert
als einen negativer PCR-Test äh von letzten Frühjahr, ja? Das kann ich, also das sozusagen, das heißt, wenn man's jetzt ernst meint, dann
muss man eigentlich jeden Tag testen. So und sogar zweimal am Tag äh wenn's äh
zwölf Stunden abgelaufen äh äh sind und man trotzdem noch irgendwie eine zweite Veranstaltung möchte, wenn man's genau nimmt, aber zumindest am nächsten Tag
kann es halt ganz anders aussehen. Die Person kann nämlich schon infiziert sein. Hm aber eben noch nicht symptomatisch.
Am nächsten Tag können dann die Symptome äh hervortreten und dann ist es schon vorbei und da gibt's auch genug Fälle
wo das versagt hat, so vor allem in Kitas, wo man einmal die Woche getestet hat, da hat
innerhalb von zwei Tests war die gesamte Kita durchinfiziert. Drei Erzieher, acht Kinder so angesteckt
die haben halt einmal die Woche getestet, was aber kein Wunder ist bei einer Haltkrankheit mit ja vier Tagen
Ähm.
Serie ist Intervall.
Serielles Intervall, serielles Intervall, danke, genau.
Man alles so drauf hat mit der Zeit.
Ja, ja, äh genau, weil äh in in den zwei Wochen kann sich der Virus schon da der Virus schon genug Zeit und selbst zweimal die Woche,
natürlich schon mal besser, aber dann ist man halt an zwei von fünf Tagen geschützt, ja? Ist besser als an ja oder zwei von sieben, je nachdem
ob da äh ob das auch fürs Wochenende geht oder nicht so, das heißt kann man schon mal festhalten, kenn niemanden, wo,
jetzt in in dem Schulszenario wirklich tägliche Tests eingeplatzt sein. Also im Moment mal das ist ja, das ist ja übertrieben und was das kostet. Mein Fünfer jeden Tag, das.
Schon ganz schön ins ins Geld, wenn ich täglich testen will, so. Das heißt, obwohl die die Dinger eigentlich super billig sind, äh scheitert es dann äh
Geld, weil niemand bereit ist, das auszugeben und wir haben auch nur sagen für Schule
sind auch nur zwanzig bis dreißig Euro pro Schüler und pro Tag überhaupt da, um die ganze Schule und den Unterricht und die Lehrer und so zu bezahlen und davon jetzt fünf,
Euro jeden Tag für Tests weggehen. So ja das geht richtig ins Geld. Also es ist schlichtweg nicht
leistbar bei den Schülerzahlen finanziell alleine schon, würde das den
ganzen Bildungsetat komplett zerschießen. So, also scheitert's schon mal in den Schulen daran, dass sie es nicht täglich machen können und äh,
aber es gibt ja noch andere Szenarien.
Man muss dazu sagen wenn äh auch nur zwei Tage die äh die Woche.
Die Schüler überhaupt in der Schule sind, so dann kann das halt noch funktionieren irgendwie, ne? Aber eben nicht für so einen richtigen Regelbetrieb.
Aber jetzt werden ja Schnelltest vor allem für Veranstaltungen auch gepusht, ne. Man möchte jetzt gerne irgendwie Veranstaltungen machen, dann wir hatten ja letzte Woche ja auch schon drüber gesprochen, dass in Berlin
äh solche Tests jetzt durchgeführt äh worden äh sind bei Veranstaltungen. Ich hatte das Beispiel Union Berlin genannt, die hatten dann in ihrem regulären
Bundesligaspieltagsprozess. Alle Leute, die ohnehin da ähm auflaufen dürfen im Rahmen dieser Hygieneregeln.
Angeboten sich schnell testen zu lassen. Das haben dann so hundertsiebzig Leute gemacht. Da ist dann halt niemand gefunden worden. Ah, das Ganze wurde dann sozusagen als Beleg äh genommen mit Sojasuper. Hat alles super funktioniert.
Wobei ich mir halt eher frage so, hm, hätte es nicht vielleicht besser funktioniert, wenn ihr jemanden gefunden hättet.
So und es war dann halt auch freiwillig und äh von daher kann man schon davon ausgehen, dass wenn irgendjemand sich nicht so gut gefühlt hat, so dass ich gedacht hat, so, ah, ich muss hier unbedingt von diesem Spieltag berichten, ne.
Eine Maske auf. Ich laufe jetzt hier mal nicht zum Test. Ich will's jetzt gar nicht wissen.
Ja und einfach bei hundertsiebzig Leuten,
ähm bis auch bei aktueller Infektionsrate ungefähr von null Komma fünf Prozent ist halt im Durchschnitt nur an die null Komma sieben null Komma acht.
Infizierte dabei, das heißt äh entweder ja man findet mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit ein oder auch kein
so, das heißt mit was nicht zwanzig, dreißig prozentiger Wahrscheinlichkeit kann's sein, dass da gar kein äh infizierter dabei gewesen ist bei den hundertsiebzig Leuten. Gerade. So.
Und ja und eigentlich.
Hätten sie aber zumindest bei der Anzahl von Leuten äh schon falsch positive wahrscheinlich finden müssen, so ein, zwei. Insofern.
Passt das irgendwie nicht so richtig, aber ja, kann äh also kann sein bei, also es ist nicht unplausibel der Art.
Also falsch positiv, sie hätten sie hätten welche als infiziert erkennen müssen, die es eigentlich gar nicht sind.
Paar von den Tests hätten einfach positiv. Also wenigstens ein oder zwei hätten positiv anschlagen müssen auch äh in der Gruppe äh wo kein Infizierter dabei ist oder oder können. Ne, so können.
Vielleicht sollten wir das mal alles nochmal kurz aufrollen, weil da herrscht ja auch total viel Konfusion mit diesen ganzen Parametern, mit Spitzifizität und.
Sensitivität und
keiner weiß, was eigentlich was, wie äh bedeutet, das ist ja auch nicht so ganz so einfach zu verstehen. Es gibt da nicht einfach so eine Zahl, die man da so drauf rechnet und dann weiß man
wie wie das gut funktioniert, sondern man muss halt so ein bisschen die Dinge auseinander äh halten.
Also es ist nicht erstmal nicht ganz offensichtlich äh wie diese Prozentzahl dann zusammenhängt mit äh was wird,
erkannt und was wird nicht erkannt und was wird falsch erkannt und so, aber ähm ja es lohnt sich sich das einmal anzuschauen oder anzuhören und dann vielleicht zu verstehen, was dahinter steckt.
Und mir hat halt am meisten geholfen, als ich das Ganze irgendwann mal als Baum aufgemalt gesehen habe, so eine Rechnung, so wo sich sagen, oben,
fängt es an mit der Zahl der Leute, die man testet und.
Verzweigt sich dann zweimal ähm bis man dann vier Gruppen,
hat oder vier Zahlen für vier Gruppen nämlich die falsch und richtig negativ positiv zu.
Nationen aus falsch und richtig und positiv und negativ.
Genau. Mhm.
Auch mal so ein bisschen Favorit ist, weil es irgendwie so eine doppelte Negation ist, ne? Aber das,
dieses Baums ist erstmal folgendes. Also man nimmt jetzt mal eine beliebige Veranstaltung, sagen wir mal, wir machen jetzt ein Fußballspiel und wir wollen jetzt zehntausend Leute reinlassen.
Und diese zehntausend Leute sollen jetzt mit Schnelltests bearbeitet werden, damit wir irgendwie,
ja im Idealfall die bösen, infizierten finden. Und um das und jetzt ist ja bei jedem Schnelltest gibt's ja so Parameter. Hör mal, die Dinger kauft.
Mhm. Aber erstmal als allererstes bevor wir den ersten Schritt äh äh machen ähm müssen wir eine Annahme darüber treffen natürlich für die Rechnung
wie viele sind wahrscheinlich wirklich infiziert von den zehntausen.
Ich wollte jetzt erstmal, ich wollte wollte nicht gleich rechnen, sondern ich wollte jetzt erstmal einen Überblick geben, wie wir da jetzt eigentlich rangehen, ne? So, das heißt, wir haben eine eine Teilnehmerzahl, die wir betrachten wollen und um dann am Ende zu diesen vier Gruppen zu kommen, ja
den falsch negativen den richtig positiven und so weiter machen wir sozusagen diese Berechnung in zwei Schritten und dazu
trennt man jetzt erstmal in der Betrachtung, um auf die richtigen Zahlen zu kommen, trennt man eben die, die tatsächlich auch infektiös sind,
von denen, die es nicht sind.
Ja. Das macht man natürlich nicht beim Testen, sondern das macht man, um das jetzt auszurechnen, was wahrscheinlich das Ergebnis dieser Testreihe.
Letzten Endes
ist und betrachtet jede dieser beiden Gruppen separat. Was machen diese Tests mit Leuten, die infektiös sind? Und was machen diese Tests mit Leuten, die es nicht sind
das ist so die Herangehensweise. Und um das jetzt richtig ausrechnen zu können, brauchen wir halt im Prinzip diese vier Zahlen. Wie viel Leute sind das überhaupt.
Wie viele sind davon überhaupt Infektions? Und dann, wie gut soll dieser Test, der jetzt hier zum Einsatz kommt,
eigentlich funktionieren. Und der wird ja mit zwei Zahlen beschrieben.
Und um hier glaube ich Konfusion zu vermeiden, sollte man erstmal die umbenennen,
weil Sensitivität und Spezifizität erstmal rockt das überhaupt nicht, dass die ganze Zeit hintereinander aussprechen äh zu dürfen und man versteht es glaube ich auch nicht. Also statt Sensitivität sagen wir einfach Empfindlichkeit. Wie,
empfindlich reagiert dieser Test auf eine tatsächliche Infektion.
Und das andere ist die Genauigkeit, ja? Wie genau äh ist dieser Test, wenn keine Infektion vorliegt.
So kann man das glaube ich ganz gut äh beschreiben. Das heißt, der eine Parameter ist für den einen Betrachtungsfall und der andere Parameter ist für den
anderen betrachtungsfall der Empfindlichkeit ist für die Infektion die Genauigkeit ist für die Nichtinfektion, ne? Und äh so kann man da jetzt so eine so eine Rechnung draus machen und jetzt nehmen wir mal
Zahlen an und schauen am besten mal, wie es eigentlich gerade so aussieht und rechnen es einfach mal durch, für zehntausend Leute wollen zum Fußball.
Genau. Und was wir dann eben.
Brauchen, äh, um diese Rechnung zu machen, ist die sogenannte Vortestswahrscheinlichkeit
und äh das ist so ein Wert, ja, so eine Annahme, die davon abhängt, was weiß man über die Gruppe, die nah getestet wird und
Wir nehmen jetzt an,
Das ist jetzt einfach eine zufällige Auswahl, über die wir nichts anderes wissen, als die durchschnittliche Inzidenz äh einschließlich Dunkelziffer in,
der Gegend und wenn wir jetzt mal einfach die aktuelle Instit
in Deutschland nehmen, wo wir jetzt bei hundertsechsundzwanzig liegen äh und rechnen dann noch eine Dunkelziffer von drei Komma fünf.
Ein
dann kommen wir auf eine Vortestwahrscheinlichkeit von null Komma fünf fünf Prozent. Also wir gehen davon aus, dass in dieser Gruppe von zehntausend,
zufällig da sind. Null Komma fünf fünf Prozent davon infiziert sind. Und das sind halt fünfundfünfzig. Ja und.
Der ganze große Rest, der sie an den neuntausendneunhundertfünfundvierzig haben halt nix. So, das sind.
Kommen jetzt zehntausend Leute, die kommen jetzt sozusagen auf dieses Stadion zu, laufen durch irgendwelche Schnelltestboxen und
Jetzt geht's da drum, diese fünfundfünfzig zu finden. Das ist ja eigentlich der Idealzustand. Man findet exakt diese fünfundfünfzig und alle anderen dürfen ins Stadion.
Ja. Genau.
Aber das sind jetzt im Prinzip die beiden Risiken, die passieren können. Risiko eins ist, jemand ist infiziert und ich.
Erkenne ihn nicht als infiziert,
Und das andere Risiko ist, jemand ist es nicht, aber wir denken, er ist es, weil das eine heißt, da ist das eine ist doof.
Weil infizierte ins Stadion gelangen. Das andere ist doof, weil nicht infizierte nicht ins Stadion gelangen und die natürlich einen Bad Day haben.
Und eigentlich umsonst äh nach Hause geschickt werden, nur weil so ein blöder Test nicht richtig funktioniert hat. So.
Weil er nicht genau genug ist.
Genau, genau, nicht genau genug. Äh so.
Genau und jetzt sind ja diese Werte, die stehen ja dann immer dran. Das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt so einen Schnelltest klickt, dann ähm ist das eine an so eine Herstellerangabe und dazu gibt's ja diese Listen, du hast das irgendwie,
dir ja mal genauer angeschaut, was was sind das das für Listen.
Ja, das ist irgendwie bei der Bundesprüfstelle für Arzneimittel, wo die Dinger auch gemeldet sind. Da müssen dann die Hersteller.
Sagen Angaben machen äh eben wie empfindlich und wie genau die Tests sind und äh geprüft wird allerdings,
für die diese Tests, für die neunzehn Tests, die im Moment zugelassen sind, ähm von staatlicher Seite nur, dass sie mindestens zu neunzig
äh äh zu achtzig Prozent empfindlich.
So dass es die Mindestanforderung, aber alle aktuellen Tests sind da viel, viel, viel, viel besser. So,
Ähm.
Was ist das für eine? Ich meine, wir sind ja eigentlich eine werbefreie Sendung äh hier, aber äh anhand der Werte kann das sowieso jeder äh äh und das müsste jetzt nicht unbedingt Werbung äh für den Test, aber ja, was ist das.
Haben auch alle so bekloppte Namen, das kann sich sowieso keiner merken. Also ich habe ja mehrere gekauft und ich kann auch für nichts bürgen oder so, weil ich jetzt auch noch.
Nichts, nichts Positives gefunden habe bisher, was irgendwie also noch nicht mal falsch positiv, aber auch nicht äh richtig positiv
Ähm das nehmen wir doch mal hier diesen
nasalen Test, also das ist so einer von den zugelassenen, wo man Nasenabstrich macht, aber man muss halt nicht mehr ganz nach hinten durch äh schieben. So, ne. Ich habe dann auch noch so einen Speicheltest gekauft, der ist ein bisschen ungenauer.
Beziehungsweise nicht nur ungenauer, sondern der ist äh un äh unempfindlicher, wo man hier gleich im richtigen Sprachduktus äh zu bleiben, ne.
Ähm,
Andere hat also jetzt eine Angabe von einer Sensitivität, also die Empfindlichkeit liegt bei achtundneunzig Komma eins Prozent.
Im Durchschnitt. Mhm.
Im Durchschnitt, genau, da gibt es dann noch so eine Schwankungsbreite, wo liegt die.
Ja, das ist so sogenannte fünfundneunzig prozentige Konfidenzintervall. Das heißt, äh das sozusagen in,
in neunzehn von zwanzig Fällen, wenn man diesen Test durchführt, kriegt man ein Ergebnis, das mindestens bei in dem Fall dreiundneunzig Komma zwei Prozent
und höchstens bei neunundneunzig Komma acht Prozent liegt. Also es ist quasi nochmal die Schwankung,
breite, wenn du so willst in der ein bisschen in der Praxis, wenn ich halt ja.
Oder beziehungsweise oft ist es so, also die Daten,
nicht mehr Genauigkeit, daher kommt auch meistens das Konfidenzintervall, weil äh als diese Zahlen ermittelt wurden.
Hat man eben nicht zehntausend.
Tests gemacht, um auf die Zahlen zu kommen, sondern eine deutlich geringere Zahl,
so äh meistens, ich meine für die Zulassung werden siebzig Tests gemacht, ja. Damit ist klar, mit mit siebzig Tests
Kannst du nicht irgendwie äh hundertstel Prozent
Werte genau ermitteln, sondern nur statistisch und je weniger Tests zu machst, umso breiter wird dieses Konfidenz
Intervall und je mehr Tests du machst, umso schmaler wird das Intervall so. Kann man sich das vorstellen, das heißt, was wir aber jetzt betrachten, denke ich, ist einmal den Durchschnittswert
und einmal den Worst Case äh Wert. Basierend einfach darauf, dass wir sagen, okay,
die Zahlen basieren jetzt auf äh einer Menge von Tests, wo sie einfach Glück gehabt haben könnt und nehm,
nur sagen, ja, den Durchschnittswert und sagen den dann den, das untere Ende des fünfundneunzig Prozent Konfidenzintervalts.
Ja
Okay, das heißt, jetzt gehen wir einfach davon aus, wir halten von diesen konkreten
Antigenschelltest, die ausreichende Menge am Start, zehntausend und genug Personal und Logistik, um das alles durchzuführen,
was ich mir auch nicht gerade besonders einfach vorstelle, weil zehntausend Leute, die so einen Test nehmen müssen, das dauert alles, das äh
dauert danach, dann muss gewartet äh äh werden, et cetera, aber um Logistik soll es jetzt erstmal nicht gehen. Wir gehen einfach mal davon aus, dass es irgendwie klappt. So,
was heißt das jetzt? Jetzt gehen wir, nehmen wir mal womit wollen wir anfangen? Erstmal mit den schlechteren Werten.
Ja, würde ich, würde ich net mit den Durchschnittswerten, weil das ist das, womit der dann immer geworben äh äh wird
muss sagen und was dann wahrscheinlich auch zu erwarten ist genau.
Okay, das heißt, zehntausend Leute kommen. Wir gehen davon aus, fünfundfünfzig davon sind heute infektiös. Das heißt ja auch, sozusagen.
Nicht hat Virus, das können auch sogar noch mehr sein, sondern sind halt auch wirklich gerade infektiös, also ansteckend. Ne? So, neuntausendneunhundertfünfundvierzig sind es nicht. Jetzt.
Haben wir ja gesagt, wir betrachten jetzt diese beiden Gruppen in diesem Ausrechnung separat und nehmen halt für die eine Gruppe den Einwert und für die andere Gruppe den anderen Wert, sprich für die Infektion nehmen wir jetzt die Empfindlichkeit.
Wie empfindlich reagiert dieser Test auf tatsächlich vorhandenes Virus in einer bestimmten Mindestmenge. Die Probe wird genommen, der Test wird durchgeführt, Leteral Flow findet äh statt und tada.
Wir finden von diesen fünfundfünfzig angeblich vierundfünfzig.
Das ist das, was uns diese Zahl, diese Empfindlichkeit von achtundneunzig Komma eins Prozent in dem Moment liefert. Heißt, einer geht uns durch ihr Lappen.
Einer darf trotzdem rein, obwohl er gerade voll infektiös ist, steht irgendwo rum und äh verteilt Corona.
Das war nicht so schön, aber ist jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, einer unter zehntausend. So,
jetzt sozusagen die reale Gefahr in diesem Szenario zumindest die äh davon ausgeht. Man kann jetzt,
glaube ich nicht davon ausgehen, dass es sich dann hier gleich um ein Superspraller-Event äh handeln wird, weil in so einem Stadion stehen die Leute ja natürlich auch relativ weit auseinander.
Plus, das hoffentlich der Supersprayder äh äh dann,
zu den vierundfünfzig rausgepickten gehört das ist schon sehr wahrscheinlich dass es sich bei der einen Person dann um eine handelt die wahrscheinlich dann auch nicht so infektiös ist.
Richtig, weil es ja nicht alle gleich infektiös sind. Genau, ne? Super Spriter ist ja mehr eine Eigenschaft, das äh,
der Person und nicht so sehr des des des Momentes. So, jetzt schauen wir uns nochmal die andere Gruppe an, weil wir haben ja noch diese neuntausendneunhundertfünfundvierzig, die wollen ja auch,
ins Stadion und die sind auch nicht infektiös. Wenn man jetzt diese neunundneunzig Komma acht Prozent Spezifizität, also diese Genauigkeit jetzt herannehmen.
Ne, Empfindlichkeit bei den Infektiösen, Genauigkeit bei den Nichtinfektiösen, dann sind das neuntausendneunhundertfünfundzwanzig, die unbehelligt ins Stadion durch äh marschieren dürfen. Aber auf der anderen Seite,
zwanzig Leute, denen gesagt wird, na hör mal, was ja Korona? Du kommst hier nicht rein. Die so wie was, ich habe Corona.
Ich habe doch kein Corona. Kannst mir viel erzählen, steht ihr drauf? Ist positiv. Du gehst mal schön nach Hause und machst am besten gleich mal äh einen PCR-Test,
Das heißt, er
quasi bei dieser Modellrechnung wohlgemerkt, ja? Zwanzig Leute der Zutritt zum Stadion ähm verwehrt und vor allem wird ihnen gesagt.
Dass ihr unter Umständen infiziert sind.
Während auf der anderen Seite, dass nur vierundfünfzig Leuten gesagt wird, die es auch wirklich sind. Also.
Über die Zahlen kann man jetzt denken, was man will, aber das ist jetzt immer einmal ausgerechnet mit den Angaben, so wie sie halt im Schnitt zu interpretieren sind.
So jetzt ist natürlich
dann noch die Frage, wie haben die Hersteller den Test tatsächlich durchgeführt? Also ich weiß nur, dass die
Bundesanstalt dafür Arzneimittel, Prüfung ähm dass.
Die, wenn die ihre Tests durchführen, da werden halt schön schöne, eingefrorene Proben
präpariert, die dann aufgetaut
werden und dann direkt zum Testen herangezogen äh werden. So, das ist natürlich eine etwas andere Situation, als wenn ich bei Leuten in der Nase rumpople und dann irgendwie
mehr oder weniger äh Virus da raushole, wobei ich davon ausgehe, dass in.
Vom Hersteller durchgeführten eigenen Tests, das auch mit berücksichtigt wurde, aber äh
Wir haben halt dann zumindest dieses fünfundneunzigprozentige Konfidenzintervall
anzusetzen, das heißt zu sagen, so eine Worst Case Betrachtung und
da sind die Prozentzahlen dann ein bisschen niedriger, so da haben wir
eine Empfindlichkeit von dreiundneunzig gegenüber achtundneunzig Prozent und eine Genauigkeit statt neunundneunzig Komma
acht von achtundneunzig Komma sechs auch noch alles hervorragende Werte, so muss man sagen, aber dann sieht's halt schon nicht mehr ganz so schön äh aus
aber ähm ja immer noch besser als wenn die Tests zu den Mindestanforderungen genügen würden oder viel besser
Ähm so und ähm da kommen wir dann auf.
In der Gruppe der fünfundfünfzig werden nur einundfünfzig rausgepickt und vier,
davon die ja eigentlich infektiös sind, werden vom Test nicht.
Erfasst und sind im Stadion. Ähm,
und auf der anderen Seite ist es halt noch bitterer, weil äh von den neuntausendneunhundertfünfundvierzig Leuten, die völlig gesund sind, werden halt hundertvierzig nach Hause geschickt.
So. Ähm das sind aber jetzt äh halt alles.
Tests, die auf den Herstellerangaben basieren. Hm in,
Studien, also in unabhängigen Studien wurden
dabei nochmal deutlich schlechtere Werte erreicht, so das muss man auch dazu sagen, das heißt ähm,
was wir hier haben, sagen ist die Betrachtung, dass wenn das alles auch so,
funktioniert wie der Hersteller uns das Glauben machen möchte. So und.
Wie gesagt, in in unabhängigen Tests ähm sind und wir haben jetzt eben diesen einen,
relativ neu und ich glaube, du hast da hast, hast du da eigentlich äh wonach hast du den ausgewählt,
den Testfachmasten zu denen genommen war, der, weil der da war oder weil der einen guten Ruf hatte oder weil der irgendwie, weil da jeder dransteht, äh.
Weil ich spezifisch nach einem gesucht habe, der so nasalen Abstrich hatte und einen, der so ein Speicheltest war,
Also mir war eh klar, ich kaufe kaufe so mehrere und ich hatte ja schon einen klassischen, der nicht vor The Public war, wo man so hinten äh eine Nase verrings irgendwie rumkratzen muss, was so ein bisschen unangenehm ist,
Und äh deswegen wollte ich da einfach mehr Bandbreite haben. Ich kann dir jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich da stundenlang über den Zahlen gekniet habe.
Kann sein, dass ich jetzt nicht in aller sensitivsten ähm erwischt habe, aber.
Nö, der ist schon der ist schon ziemlich gut, den du da äh hast. Also mein es gibt ja da
diese Liste Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel und Medizinprodukte heißt das Ding heißt es Institut korrekt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich aber da ganz zahlend irgendwie was anderes gesagt ähm.
Ja die haben da so eine lange Liste, ne, mit äh allen Details.
Ja, also sie haben dort zwei Listen, muss man wissen, das eine ist sozusagen die Liste.
Oder wir haben eine Datenbank dahinter und auf der einen.
Webseite, die man erstmal erreicht ähm wird nur eine verkürzte Spaltenanzahl angezeigt und unter anderem,
wird eben nicht angezeigt,
äh halt die Spezifizität und Sensitivität, also Empfindlichkeit und Genauigkeit, aber ähm ja.
Wenn ich jetzt in die Liste gucke, dann schwankt jetzt die Empfindlichkeit.
Zwischen.
Der Test zwischen zweiundachtzig Komma sieben Prozent, das ist aber nur einer einer mit neunzig dabei, einer mit.
Einundneunzig vier ja also.
Man sieht schon die Tests haben doch eine erhebliche Schwankungsbreite, also man sollte dann vielleicht schon.
Bei der Auswahl der Tests, die man besorgt.
Einen Blick auf die Zahlen werfen und gerade natürlich für Screenings größerer Gruppen sind viele dieser Tests einfach,
ungeeignet, weil äh wir wenn wir jetzt nur einen Test mit neunzig,
prozentiger mh Empfindlichkeit haben, dann gehen uns.
Schon ja äh was wären das dann sechs Leute durch die Lappen.
Die ins Stadion kommen von den fünfundfünfzig so und bei achtzig Prozent werden's dann schon zwölf wobei wie gesagt so schlechte Tests gibt's dann nicht. Also.
Der der Punkt ist, hm dass man ja.
Ohne den genauen Test auch zu kennen und die die Werte zu kennen da Risikoläuf, dass da halt schon.
Ein paar Leute durchkommen, aber vor allen Dingen eben auch viele nach Hause geschickt werden, die einfach gesund sind, was jetzt vielleicht im Stadionfall nicht so das Problem ist, aber wenn ich die natürlich.
In der Schule einsetze oder.
In einem Unternehmen, dann nervt es natürlich ganz schön, wenn ich halt ständig positive.
Fälle äh habe, die dann äh eine PCA machen und dann feststellen, war nichts und.
Je nachdem ich habe halt gehört, dass zwischen weiß nicht zwanzig und vierzig Prozent der positiven Schnelltests
sich dann teilweise nicht bestätigen in der PCA. Und es gab sogar Raten irgendwo plötzlich von sechzig Prozent, dass da wurde der Test da war dann wohl irgendwie falsch durchgeführt oder bei der falschen Temperatur oder so
Und das kann halt auch passieren, ja. Da muss man halt schon ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ja, was machen wir jetzt aus der ganzen Geschichte so? Also einfach mal so salopp gefragt.
Wobei können uns Schnelltests jetzt helfen und ab wann können sie uns eigentlich
also welchen Aufwand muss man treiben, dass er einem wirklich helfen können und wo können sie auch eher kontraproduktiv sein. Wenn du das mit den Schulen hast, schon so ein bisschen angesprochen, also generell, wenn man halt nicht nur sozusagen längere Zeiträume
möchte muss man halt eigentlich auch öfter testen, weil diese Tests bestenfalls für den Tag halten. Bestenfalls.
Und gut für uns, wenn man jetzt eine Gruppe hat, die für längere Zeit zusammen.
Ist so, dann müsste man trotzdem eigentlich die ersten drei Tage jeden Tag testen, weil das halt sein kann, dass eben am ersten Tag äh infizierte halt,
noch nicht als infektiös.
Erkannt werden, weil sie noch nicht infektiös sind, aber dann eben so zwei, drei Tage später dann halt der Test dann doch anschlägt. So, also muss schon recht genau wissen
eigentlich was man tut in in welchem Fall. Ja, für die, für das Stadionbeispiel,
ist es dann nur eine Frage, ist vermutlich würde ich sagen ist es auch im Freien,
Und wenn die Leute dann auch noch Masken tragen, so und alle,
Tests ordentlich durchgeführt worden sind. So dann würde ich das Risiko tatsächlich sogar für vertretbar halten. Aber.
Frage ist halt, o,
eben all die Bedingungen erfüllt sind und wie das dann halt, wie noch dann das Restrisiko aussieht, dass die Tests falsch du,
geführt werden und einzelne Leute die Tests nicht machen oder so und das Ganze hängt natürlich extrem.
Von der Vortestwahrscheinlichkeit ab. Das heißt bei einer hohen Institanz schlüpfen wir.
Eben mehr Leute durch. So dass.
Ich sagen würde, dass ja bei einer niedrigen Institz so von, sag mal in der Größenordnung,
von zwanzig vielleicht kann man mit solchen Tests tatsächlich dann.
Ja die die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand durchschlüpft, ziemlich weit.
Reduzieren. Sieht man dann auch an der Rechnung angenommen die Hälfte der Leute wären infiziert, die dahin kommen. So,
guck gerade mal, wo habe ich denn, wo haben wir denn die die Zahlen so ähm.
Hilft.
Ja, na ja, wenn man mal einfach nur an äh,
so aus irgendeinem Grund waren die alle vorher feiern zusammen so in einer großen Fangruppe und die Hälfte davon äh ist jetzt.
Dann schlüpfen dir mal locker so tausend irgendwie durch.
Mhm. Bei ja also bei bei fünfzig Prozent ja sind's.
Je nachdem, also in dem, in dem Worst Case sogar schlüpfen dir dann dreihundertvierzig durch von von fünftausend infiziert,
Das heißt,
wenn ich den Test mache äh muss ich halt eben auch sehr viel sagen, die über die Vortestwahrscheinlichkeit wissen und
in der Kita möglicherweise, in der Kitasituation
wo die alle dann schon zusammen waren und ich teste die alle durch, ist natürlich auch die Vortestwahrscheinlichkeit nochmal eine ganz andere
Aber dafür sind die Zahlen natürlich auch entsprechend klein. Aber je höher die,
Aktuelle Infektionsrate, je höher die Inzidenz, umso.
Mehr Leute schlüpfen durch, die infiziert sind. Einfach bei äh aus einer,
Gruppe, die man, die man testet. So, eigentlich logisch, klar. Äh aber sollte man.
Hab eben tausend gesagt, natürlich Quatsch fünfundneunzig sind es wenn wenn man wirklich die Hälfte infektiös ist vor zehntausend, dann,
langen noch fünfundneunzig rein, aber es werden auch viertausendneunhundertfünf werden raussortiert. Also das hilft dann auf jeden Fall auch schon.
Ja
Meine unter dieser dieser das ist ja auch noch so ein Gesichtspunkt, ne? Dieser, ist ja so ein anderes Argument pro Schnelltest, was sie auch durchaus nachvollziehen kann, ist wenn man sie durchführt.
Bringt das zwar für manche Leute so ein bisschen Unwill, ne, weil sie falsch.
Positiven sozusagen Stress haben und dann unnützerweise getestet werden. Aber es werden ja dann auch welche gefunden.
Ja, also dieses regelmäßige Testen.
Dieses massenhafte Testen in einer größeren Gruppe findet dann ja auch relativ schnell äh Leute, die sonst vielleicht ja gar nicht gewusst hätten, dass sie äh gerade dabei sind, irgendwie Leute anzustecken.
Man kann ja auch davon ausgehen, dass also ich weiß nicht, kann man davon ausgehen, aber ich würde es jetzt mal so sehen.
Wenn Leute sich krank fühlen in so einer Pandemie, dann tendieren sie dann, tendieren sie zumindest dazu.
Vielleicht doch von so einer Veranstaltung Abstand zu nehmen. Wenn du eh schon am Husten bist und so.
Aber die Asymphomatischen, die sind ja so ein bisschen das Problem, die sozusagen keine Symptome zeigen, aber trotzdem infektiös äh sind, ne. Das senkt vielleicht dann auch so diese vortestwahrscheinlichkeit auch nochmal so ein bisschen ab.
Weil du schon davon ausgehen kannst, dass Leute die dann eben krank.
Sind, sich auch krank fühlen, dann eben hier doch nicht zu dieser Gruppe gehört, sondern das ist eigentlich nur unter diesen asymphomatischen äh fischst und dann müsste man wieder auf Alter gucken und so weiter.
Jetzt nehmen wir nochmal das Schülerbeispiel. Wir haben elf Millionen Schüler in Deutschland an ähm ja allgemein und berufsbildenden Schulen.
Und.
Nehmen dann einfach mal wieder die null Komma fünf fünf Prozent. Ja und würden jetzt einmal die gesamte Schülerschaft,
durchtesten, dann hätten wir gerade aktuell ungefähr sechzigtausend,
infizierte Schüler oder infektiöse Schüler in Deutschland. Hm und,
davon würden tatsächlich auch die meisten aussortiert, aber viertausendeinhundertvierzehn Schüler, wenn man alle durchtestet würden.
Jetzt mit der ähm ja,
Empfindlichkeitsrechnung bei dreiundneunzig Komma zwei Prozent, also im unteren Ende vom Konfidenzintervall durchschlüpfen. So, ja. Ähm,
Ja, also weiß nicht, wenn bei täglichem Schnelltesten gut.
Meisten werden rausgepickt und am nächsten Tag mit ein bisschen Glück so äh wieder mehr davon
aber ja trotzdem ja für viertausend Schüler, aber hundertdreiundfünfzigtausend Schüler,
könnten nicht am Unterricht teilnehmen, weil sie fälschlicherweise hm ja, einem positiven Schnelltest haben und ich weiß jetzt
auch nicht was das mit so einem Kind macht, wenn es positiv äh schnell getestet wird, erstmal wahrscheinlich am Ende nichts, weil die weil sich das halt alles schon längst rumgesprochen hat und sagen, ah ja, komm, ich hatte jetzt auch schon dreimal
einen Schnelltest und da war irgendwie auch nichts und ähm ja hm insofern.
Das ist ja auch tatsächlich etwas, was was man oft hört, ne? Also ich meine, es gibt so so Extremfälle, wo.
Test irgendwie überhaupt nicht funktioniert, wo äh am laufenden Meter äh Leute als als als positiv gemeldet sind, wo sich das später nicht bestätigt. Das
habe ich gehört, solche Fälle, ja, in Krankenhäusern. So, was weiß ich.
Das kann unter anderem wohl daran liegen, dass bestimmte Leute vielleicht mit einem anderen Corona Virus,
infiziert sind und das eigentlich Kreuzreaktivität oder durch anderes
Weiß ich nicht, genetisches Material, äh was sie, was sie in sich haben
immer positiv getestet werden mit bei 'nem bestimmten Schnelltests, äh, obwohl dann die PCR immer negativ ist oder solche Fälle gibt's auch.
Aber ich meine nicht, dass eine Person immer positiv ist, sondern das eben wirklich bei vielen Personen, die getestet werden, immer sehr viele falsch positiv sind. Also wo die
eine Genauigkeit einfach sehr viel geringer ist, als wir jetzt hier gerechnet haben.
Ähm aber was ich meine ist, es gibt eben auch diese Fälle ähm gut, die wissen's dann irgendwann, dass bei denen ein bestimmter Schnelltest immer positiv anschlägt, obwohl ähm da nichts ist. So, also.
Einfach mal den Stelltest wechseln. Ich wollte auch eher darauf hinaus, dass es natürlich dann auch wieder dieses Misstrauen erzeugt, ne? Das hört man dann schnell von den Leuten, ja, die Schnelltests, die taugen ja alle nichts, weil und so, ne.
Also als als Fazit würde ich sagen, es ist eine ambivalente Sache mit den Schnelltesten. Man muss wissen, was man tut.
Man muss die richtigen Dinge tun, man braucht die richtigen Schnelltests und man muss
sich auch sehr genau informieren, zum Beispiel bei welcher Temperatur und anderen Dingen äh dieser spezielle Schnelltest äh eigentlich durchgeführt werden kann, so. Und ja,
dann können Sie einen Beitrag leisten, aber Sie sind kein Wundermittel.
Sind so wie jetzt der Einsatz an Schulen geplant ist, ähm mit zwei Mal die Woche. Gut, wenn du sagst, die Schüler gehen auch in die Woche in die Schule, dann ist es okay. Aber.
Halt eigentlich jeden Tag vor Unterricht stattfindet, müssen auch alle getestet werden, sonst bringt das nichts und da die Tests aber zudem auch noch freiwillig sind, ja
müssten wir natürlich die Prozentraten dann entsprechend um den Freiwilligenanteil nochmal äh reduzieren
und ja mit anderen Worten,
Ich glaube, Schnelltests sind jetzt in der politischen Debatte zumindest primär so ein Beruhigungsmittel für
Ähm in der Lockerungsdebatte äh einfach ist es die Hauptanwendung von Schnelltests. Äh denke ich ähm.
Ja
Und ansonsten ja äh möchte ich sie nicht runtermachen, sie sind, ich meine, sie haben beeindruckende
Empfindlichkeit und beeindruckende Genauigkeitswerte, das ist schon ziemlich der Hammer und die sind ein wichtiges diagnostisches Mittel
aber äh es wird eben auch in der Debatte viel Schindluder getrieben gerade da.
Vor allem muss man halt auch eins sehen. Diese Schnelltests können dazu beitragen, dass man ein Infektions
Ausbruch. Früher findet im Rahmen Held und dadurch quasi indirekt Leute schützt. So ein bisschen auch wie die Corona Warnap in gewisser Hinsicht, ne? Die wird auch indikt. Aber.
Sie ist halt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne eine Maßnahme, die das Infektionsgeschehen als solches,
eindämmt. Ist nicht so, dass man jetzt sagt, oh jetzt wo wir Schnelltest in Schulen haben, gehen die Zahlen runter.
Sondern der eigentliche Risiko geht davon aus.
Dass die Schulen offen haben und Leute dort Kontakte haben und man versucht quasi nur die Auswirkungen, die das in negativer Hinsicht zwangsläufig hat
Durch die Schnelltest ein bisschen in Grenzen zu halten, aber man krieg
nicht die umgekehrte Bewegung hin, die man ja eigentlich haben will, wenn man so hohe Institenzen hat, wie wir sie jetzt gerade haben
Sprich die Frage, was sollen wir jetzt tun? Wir haben hohe Zahlen, unser Airwert liegt über eins und äh alles läuft wieder exponentiell auf eine hohe Belastung raus. Kann nicht sein, na ja, wir haben aber Schnelltest,
Weil mit diesem Schnelltest kriegst du auf jeden Fall das Geschehen nicht in den Griff. Du kannst aber das Risiko für bestimmte Aktivitäten senken.
Und kann sagen für 'ne Veranstaltung die in zeitlich überschaubaren Bereich hat, ja? Wenn man eben auch diese falsch positiven Tests,
dann auch abgefedert bekommt, weil Leute ja auch enttäuscht sind und so weiter, ja äh dann dann kann man, sagen wir mal, das das Risiko, das zusätzliche Risiko durch diese Veranstaltung, dieses temporäre Ding.
Irgendwie im Griff halten, aber es wird niemals so gut funktionieren wie keine Veranstal.
Plus was wünschenswert wäre, aber das ist erst ab zweitausendzweiundzwanzig geplant, dass äh tatsächlich diese Schnelltests,
richtig getestet werden von amtlicher Seite. Hm,
Wie gesagt, bisher gibt's halt nur diesen ja äh kleinen Tests, der da gemacht wird und.
Im Moment passen eben die Studien, die es gibt und die Metastudien, die dazu gemacht wurden in der Wissenschaft nicht so ganz mit den Herstellerangaben,
das ist sozusagen das zweite Ding, also äh das, was in der Datenbank dort steht, was sicherlich auch Ergebnis von irgendwelchen Studien ist, äh.
Ist jetzt nicht dasselbe, was.
Sagen bei anderen Studien rausgekommen ist und ja, worauf verlassen wir uns äh jetzt? Also, wir brauchen mehr Studien.
Genau, noch mehr Studien.
Bleiben wir aber trotzdem jetzt nochmal ähm bei Veranstaltungen, weil ich ähm wollte mal an dieser Stelle ein neues.
Thema nochmal aufrufen.
Und zwar konkret geht es hier um eine der größten Veranstaltungen in Deutschland, die normalerweise stattfindet, nämlich die Fusion. Weiß nicht, warst du schon mal auf der Fusion.
Wir waren zusammen da.
Ach wirklich? Wir waren zusammen da.
Ja. Das ist aber schon die mehr als zehn Jahre her äh.
Eine Weile her mindestens, ja.
Ja, es muss zweitausendsechs oder so gewesen sein, zweitausendsechs.
Kann alles sein. Ich habe, ich habe keine Erinnerungen mehr.
Ich weiß, dass deswegen, äh, weil wir mit einem neuen Auto gefahren sind damals und das hab ich halt immer noch und ja.
A, okay, verstehe.
Weil das nämlich hinterher so eingesaut war, das kann ich mich hier kann ich mich auch noch so dran erinnern, weil ich nämlich,
im Zelt dann über meinen Schlüssel gerollt bin und ähm dann sich alle vier Fenster geöffnet hatten und dann an dem Auto
so die ganze Parade dann von Anreisenden vorbeigefahren ist und den Staub aufgewirbelt hat und dann die Sitze so mit einer halben Zentimeter hohen Staubschicht bedeckt waren. Deswegen kann ich mich da noch ganz gut dran erinnern
ähm ja.
Okay, zu viele Details
äh jetzt geht's erstmal um folgendes. So, ein Film mit dieser Veranstaltung nicht vertraut ist, vielleicht ein paar Worte dazu ist eine der größten Open Air Veranstaltungen in Deutschland, ein alternatives Festival
wo also normalerweise offiziell siebzigtausend Leute auflaufen. Unterm Strich sind's wahrscheinlich noch ein paar mehr, aber egal. Und da ist äh zwar auch eine ganze Menge Platz, aber das ist auch schon ziemlich eng. Letztes Jahr
selber verzichtet und hat halt gesagt, okay, hier ist Pande Miever, wir setzen mal aus. Freiwillig.
War dann allerdings so ein bisschen angefressen, nachvollziehbarerweise, als dann im Sommer eigentlich so in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, da ist ja die Fusion, ne? Ähm überall.
Viel Campingplatzaktivität war und überhaupt viel draußen so Tourismus stattgefunden hat. Am Ende war ja der Sommer noch verhältnismäßig entspannt für uns.
Und äh dieses Jahr denken die sich halt so also wir wollen aber feiern.
Und haben sich jetzt ein Testkonzept überlegt wie sie das denn machen konnten,
und gehen jetzt hier irgendwie ein paar ganz interessante Schritte, die so noch nicht äh gesehen wurden,
Das Ganze ist jetzt ein Konzept, das haben sie vorgestellt. Das waren sie in irgendeiner Form beantragen oder vielleicht auch schon beantragt haben. Das weiß ich jetzt im Einzelnen gar nicht so genau
Sprich, das soll dann halt in irgendeiner Form von den zuständigen Behörden abgesegnet werden oder eben auch nicht.
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie kann man das machen? Wie kann man irgendwie eine Veranstaltung, also es geht äh von vornherein die Veranstaltung wird schon mal aufgeteilt. Also man.
Sagt okay, wir machen zwei Veranstaltungen, die je fünfunddreißigtausend Teilnehmer hat,
Ne, also wir halbieren sozusagen schon mal von vornherein die Veranstaltung, um grundsätzlich mehr Raum zu schaffen und das ist auch ehrlich gesagt bei der Veranstaltung ganz angemessen, weil mit Vollbesetzung ist es da halt teilweise doch ganz schön voll.
Und so die Hälfte des wird sicherlich schon eine ganze Menge bringen. Was wollen sie jetzt also tun? Sie wollen tatsächlich,
hier so eine äh umfangreiche Teststrategie fahren und im Gegensatz zu einer Veranstaltung nicht nur auf Schnelltest setzen, sondern tatsächlich auch auf PCR-Tests.
Jetzt läuft das halt normalerweise so, die Leute reisen da an und sind dann da auch ein paar Tage. Das heißt, Schnelltest greift natürlich allein schon deshalb nicht, weil,
ein paar Tage da bist und das haben wir ja gerade ausführlich diskutiert,
helfen dir halt Schnelltest jetzt auch nichts, ne? Erstmal würden dir eine ganze Menge Leute äh würdest du eine ganze Menge Leute unschuldig nach Hause schicken, du würdest ähm vor allem viele nicht finden und vor allem der Schnelltest.
Greift eben nur die.
Infiktöse Zeit ab und kann halt maximal für vierundzwanzig Stunden gelten, wenn überhaupt. Und das ist natürlich für so eine mehrtägige Veranstaltung
ungeeignet. Also sollen ihr PCR-Tests zum Einsatz kommen und da das Bits ähm
angeschlossenen Laboren, alles viel zu lange dauert und viel zu teuer ist natürlich auch. Wollen sie ihre eigene ihr eigenes PCR-Labor on Zeit haben.
Das heißt, sie kaufen sich tatsächlich PCR-Maschinen.
Mit dem passenden Personal dazu, die das bedienen können, was jetzt nicht so kompliziert ist, ja? Also eine PCR-Maschine zu bedienen ist Standard für einen medizinisch technischen Assistenten.
Sag ich jetzt mal, zumindest jemand, der.
Da wir schon immer vertraut ist, kann sozusagen kann diese Dinge Proben vorbereiten, so dass die in so eine Maschine eingesetzt werden können. Und wir haben hier glaube ich PCR-Test auch schon mal besprochen
Im Kern ist so eine PCR-Maschine, so eine Art äh programmierbarer Durchlauferhitzer.
Ist besser, weil da läuft nichts durch, ne? Genau, Thermo-Cycler nennt man das. Also es ist im Prinzip ein Ofen, genau der programmierbar ist und um diese äh RNA,
Duplizierungsprozesse durchzuführen, wird halt, wenn dann diese Proben in so einem definierten äh und sehr strikt eingehaltenen Temperaturrahmen immer wieder erwärmt und wieder abgekühlt und das wird dann halt mehrfach äh durchlaufen und
in dem Moment müssen sie sich dann eben das Genmaterial entsprechend dupliziert haben und wenn da eben das, was man gesucht hat, nämlich.
Das also Teile des Saaskopf zwei, wenn also da wirklich Virus äh drin ist, dann sollte sich das eben auch entsprechend ähm dupliziert haben und dann kann man eben am Ende mit dieser Maschine auch sehen, was jetzt hier
eine infizierte Probe ist und was nicht.
Und das ist sozusagen das Modell, was sie hier äh fahren, das heißt äh sie denken das komplett durch von der Anreise her, also üblicherweise reisen die Leute ja entweder mit eigenen Fahrzeugen an oder mit dem Bus, wenn du mit dem Bus machst, dann machst du
den PCR-Test quasi schon bei der Busababreise. Machst einen Schnelltest für den Bus.
Ja. Und äh setzt sich dann in den Bus alle Masken auf, fährst dahin.
Und dein PCR-Test, den du aber gerade auch noch in Auftrag gegeben hast, der ist dann sozusagen durch, wenn du ankommst und dann kannst du halt Pech haben und.
Negatives Ergebnis haben. Aber wenn halt beide Tests dann was habe ich gesagt,
kannst Pech haben und ein positives äh ja, ist immer alles falsch rum. Äh also
kannst halt Pech haben und es kann dir halt nachgewiesen werden, dass du eben äh infiziert bist, dann wirst du eben entsprechend nicht reingelassen und dann ist er äh Zugangsbeschränkung zum Gelände halt über RFID-Chips am äh Handgelenk et cetera P
P ist also alles irgendwie entsprechend personalisiert. Dann darfst du dann eben rein
wenn alles okay ist, kannst da äh an der Party teilnehmen und nach zwei Tagen.
Wird aber dann äh wenn alle nochmal vom Acker geführt, also wenn du dann sozusagen vor Ort bist, dann musst du nochmal einen äh Test abgeben.
Und da wird in einem zweiten Durchgang alle Teilnehmer vor Ort nochmal äh durch Puling Tests äh getestet. Das heißt, man benutzt dieselbe PCR Infrastruktur, aber da man ja in dem Moment
alle, die da sind, gleichzeitig testen muss, wird dann entsprechend Puling gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, mit welchem Faktor, sagen wir mal, eins und zehn. Das heißt, du nimmst zehn Proben und testest die gemeinsam und wenn halt,
positiv ist, dann musst du halt äh alle einzeln nochmal nachtesten. Ja und wer dann diesen Test auch noch übersteht, der darf dann halt auch bleiben.
Das ist das Testkonzept jetzt mal ganz grob vorgestellt.
Plus übt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, soll's dann auch noch irgendwie.
Ja diese in Berlin Hamburg und Leipzig Teststationen geben, wo du auch, wenn du mit einem PKW anreist, äh, vorher hinfahren
kannst, oder? Ja und
dich dann dort testen lassen kannst und die sind wohl dann angeschlossen, scannen die Tickets und dann machen dann den PCR-Test und
dann ja kann man weiterfahren und wenn man dann das selbe wie mit der Busvariante was zu glaube ich erzählt hast
plus, dass sie glaube ich noch, äh, wie ich hier ähm oder habe ich jetzt was falsches gesagt.
Nö, das war das passt schon. Mhm.
Äh ähm.
Nee, du kannst dich da auch äh sozusagen testen lassen, wenn du dich auf den Weg machst. Mhm. Und dann ist das äh eben auch gleich mit deinem Ticket verbunden.
Mhm. Genau und du kannst aber auch einfach vor äh einfach hinfahren und dann vor Ort äh da getestet werden plus, dass sie dann noch irgendwie mit.
Und Lieferanten und so haben sie da auch berücksichtigt. Ja. Ja.
Dazu vielleicht für die, die jetzt schon einen skeptischen Blick,
drauf haben und vielleicht nochmal eine Sache äh wer wer es konkret hier auch die die Diffusen, den Kulturkosmos, den eigentlichen Betreiber der Veranstaltung und vielleicht auch diese Szene nicht kennt.
Dieser Leute, die das machen.
Das sind auch die Leute, die diese Art Leute, diese Art Leute, ja. Das sind die Leute, die hier auch gerade zumindest in Berlin, aber auch an anderen Stellen, die Impfzentren betreiben.
Das sind diese.
Partyleute, die vielleicht von außen oft wahrgenommen werden als wie crazy Freaks, was sie sicherlich teilweise auch sind, ja? Aber vor allem sind sie eins. Sie sind die Art Leute,
die Logistik so richtig drauf haben, weil so eine Infrastruktur
da aufzuziehen und irgendwie mal eben für siebzigtausend Leute so eine Kleinstadt für drei Tage zu betreiben, die da irgendwie alle am
am Feiern sind, die irgendwie medizinisch, psychologisch äh essenstechnisch äh organisatorisch betreut werden müssen in gewisser Hinsicht, wo du alle Eventualitäten hast, wo irgendwie aller möglicher Crazy Kram
passiert, auf den du kurzfristig reagieren wirst, wo wo Dinge gebaut werden müssen, wo
Systeme betrieben werden müssen, unter höchstem Druck, die sehr, sehr, sehr zuverlässig funktionieren müssen. Also auch in digitaler Hinsicht. Die haben das ganz schön drauf. Und das ist ehrlich gesagt so eine Gruppe von Leuten, denen ich irgendwie sehr viel mehr zutraue als,
all die ganzen anderen Infrastrukturen über die wir hier schon oft gesprochen haben, die es halt irgendwie noch nicht mal schaffen. So und so einen Test irgendwie in so eine App reinzumelden
in Deutschland, ne? Was ja in gewisser Hinsicht,
durchaus eine leistbare Funktionalität ist, so. Hier ist das halt tatsächlich alles voll integriert.
Dacht und geplant und ehrlich gesagt, ich hab da relativ großes Zutrauen, dass das dann halt auch funktionieren wird.
Weil davon hängt die ganze Veranstaltung ab und das ist den Leuten eine Menge wert. Ich finde es bemerkenswert äh,
Und vor allem finde ich es auch bemerkenswert, wie sie's halt auch pitchen, weil sie einfach sagen. Es geht dadrum.
Eine ein gewisses Maß an an Infektionssicherheit.
Herzustellen. Das ist das, was wir mit den ganzen anderen Maßnahmen.
Wir wollen Leute beschützen und wir wollen Leute irgendwie davor bewahren so. Und Tests sind sozusagen hier der Weg,
PCR-Tests haben gegenüber den Schnelltest, die wir jetzt ausführlich besprochen haben, halt zahlreiche Vorteile. Sie erkennen halt eine eine Infektion, aber sie erkennen eben auch, dass Virus schon bevor es infektiös ist. Und auch noch lange danach. Also die.
Anwesenheit eines Virus in einem Menschen ist mit diesem Test mit sehr hoher Zuverlässigkeit testbar.
Und das ist ja im Prinzip auch das Instrument, auf dem die gesamte Betrachtung der Pandemie im letzten Jahr funktioniert hat.
Und sowas dann hier zum eins äh Einsatz zu bringen schafft halt schon eine Situation für eine Veranstaltung, die ja dann auch draußen ist, ne? Im Sommer ähm wo man sagen kann.
Unter diesen Bedingungen, wo alle Leute durchgetestet sind. Ist jetzt.
Der Aufenthalt innerhalb dieses Geländes auch nicht gefährlicher oder vielleicht sogar noch ungefährlicher als im Supermarkt.
Körn. Ciao.
Ja. Ja, ich mein.
Gut grundsätzlich, manchmal hängt natürlich auch, um, wenn man jetzt beurteilen möchte, wie gefährlich oder wie sicher ist das denn, wie wir jetzt gerade auch äh,
durchaus gesehen haben, es hängt auch bei den PCR-Tests natürlich davon ab. Ähm wie.
Hoch die Vortestwahrscheinlichkeit beziehungsweise wie hoch die Institenz zu dem Zeitpunkt dann ist so.
Und.
Ja ähm das Problem ist ähm so ich habe.
Zur ja Sensitivität und Spezifizität,
von PCR Tests ähm gibt es halt ganz viele verwirrende
Publikation ähm so und äh auch eine riesengroße Spannung,
breite, sodass diese Rechnung, diese schöne Rechnung, die wir jetzt für die Schnelltests gemacht äh haben, wer jetzt gar nicht.
Durchführen.
Können äh aber ja äh generell wollen wir natürlich sagen, äh sind natürlich die PCA-Tests besser so. Hm.
Aber genaue Zahlen, so äh fehlen halt äh einfach.
Ja und definitiv sind sie halt nicht.
Auch äh ja PCR-Tests sind eben nicht zu hundert Prozent.
Empfindlich, das heißt äh es gibt eben auch und das hängt dann, das wissen wir ja.
Er hängt dann halt sehr stark davon ab wie die Proben entnommen,
werden, aber ja, ich gehe mal davon aus, dass das gut gemacht wird, aber,
so wenn das nicht nicht gut läuft oder so, dann hat man auch so schon Raten von dreißig Prozent, die äh durchrutschen. So dasselbe.
Trifft dann aber natürlich,
zwangsläufig auch auf die äh Antigentests zu äh so aber theoretisch, zumindest äh können die halt schon extrem gute Werte erreichen, aber leider
kann ich das halt hier nicht quantifizieren. Ähm ja.
Auf jeden Fall einen Bolt Move. Ich bin gespannt, was die Behörden dazu sagen. Ähm,
Normalerweise sind hier eher so ein bisschen
ja veranstaltungsfeindlich habe ich das Gefühl, wenn's denn dann konkret drauf ankommt, zu Recht, oft im Moment, würde ich sagen, aber ja, auf der anderen Seite,
Ja
Viel sicherer geht's wahrscheinlich nicht und außerdem würden sie dann wahrscheinlich auch noch einen Beitrag leisten um noch einen Haufen Leute rauszufischen äh die äh dann infiziert sind und
Ähm.
Ja und die sind kostenlos auch noch beziehungsweise im Ticketpreis enthalten oder wie immer man das auch nennen möchte äh ja.
Ja ja also klar, ich meine die Kosten müssen natürlich irgendwie wieder rein äh kommen. Ich kenne ja jetzt keine keine konkreten äh äh
Zahlen, ich hab's mal so versucht, mir mal so ein bisschen salopp äh herbeizurechnen. Äh es hängt so ein bisschen davon ab, was die
mein wie viele Geräte sie da kaufen müssen und ich habe keine Ahnung, was die dann äh sozusagen noch an an realen Pro äh Testkosten haben,
auf Reagenzien et cetera, dann brauchst du natürlich noch das Personal, musst den ganzen Kram irgendwie transportieren, betreiben trainieren, äh zuverlässig äh machen, also
es ist nicht ohne Kosten
auf der anderen Seite ist es ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt eine einmalige Beschaffung, also während wir halt diese Schnelltests danach im Wesentlichen einfach wegschmeißt und entsorgst
hast du zwar hier auch Abfall, ne? Plastikabfall ist bei diesem ganzen Test äh sowieso äh gegeben äh
kannst du natürlich diese Maschinen, wenn's dann eben gut funktioniert bei anderen Veranstaltungen halt auch wieder zum Einsatz bringen.
Ja, ich hoffe, wann ist sie? Wann soll die stattfinden.
Ende Juni.
Ja also da besteht dann zumindest Hoffnung äh hm.
Das Problem ist natürlich, die brauchen auch irgendwann natürlich eine Zusage, ne? Weil irgendwann irgendwann muss so halt solche Sachen dann auch mal planen und verbindlich äh äh Dinge kaufen, bestellen, durchführen, Personal muss sich Zei
nehmen muss, akquiriert werden muss äh müssen Verträge, Lieferverträge, auch für die Veranstaltung als solche eingegangen werden, Mieten, et cetera PP.
Äh das ist eine spielte Rolle.
Fahren oder?
Eigentlich ist der Zug schon abgefahren und ich weiß aus dem aus dem Festivalbereich.
Viele haben ja auch Jerefestivals, die großen Festivals haben ja schon abgesagt, weil so dieses klassischen.
Festivals, sagen wir mal, so wie Wacken und so weiter. Die basieren auf einem professionellen Geflecht, wo du eben Zusagen machen musst, die du jetzt nicht,
tun kannst und wo dir auch derzeit keine Versicherung mehr einspringt. Diese unabhängigen Alternativenveranstaltungen haben den Vorteil, dass sie eben,
in der Lage sind auf der einen Seite auf so eine Community aufzubauen, die bereit ist, sagen wir mal auch noch auf den letzten Drücker zu liefern,
die alle verstanden haben wie hier die Zwänge und Abhängigkeiten sind, die sozusagen auch bereit sind so ein bisschen selber mit ins Risiko zu gehen.
Soweit es ihnen äh möglich ist, ja? Und dass sie eben auch auf Basis dieser Strukturen sehr schnell agieren können.
Das heißt, sie können dann auch noch mit kürzeren Zeiträumen arbeiten, beim bei der Fusion. Konkret ist es ja so, das weiß ja auch nicht unbedingt jeder.
Das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur so eine große Veranstaltung, die irgendwo stattfindet, sondern das Ganze findet ihr auf einem Gelände statt, was diese den Leuten auch noch selber gehört. Das ist so ein ehemaliger Flugplatz und der ist da e,
Ja, die Frage ist nur, findet da jetzt gerade eine Veranstaltung statt oder nicht. Das heißt, du musst äh da ist jetzt nicht auch noch so eine Miete und irgendwie äh so weiter mit äh äh verbunden. Die haben natürlich auch ihre Kosten, auf die sie gerne kommen würden,
aber das sind alles so Faktoren, die helfen. Am Ende kannst du natürlich nicht zwei Wochen vorher sagen. Ja okay, wir machen das.
Oder zwei Wochen vorher sagen, ja, nee, kann doch nicht stattfinden, sondern irgendwo muss es halt so ein, so einen Moment geben, wo es heißt Hop oder Top, ne? Aber wenn dann eben der Rest der Republik dann doch wieder irgendwie Campingurlaub macht.
Ja? Ohne, dass da alle jeden Tag äh mit PCR-Tests irgendwie den Zugang zum Campingplatz erhalten, dann sagen die Sicherheit auch.
Ja, wollt ihr uns eigentlich verarschen so? Also ich meine, was sollen wir uns denn noch einfallen lassen.
Ja. Ja und natürlich ich mein
Ähm ja, wenn man sich auf der anderen Seite äh anguckt, gutes Schreiben, die ja auch ähm so Autos werden produziert.
Waffen werden produziert. Alles wird produziert, äh, eigentlich und äh ja.
Nur die Kultur findet nicht statt.
Genau, alles, alles was Spaß macht, ist verboten und alles was äh mit Arbeit zu tun hat, äh da wird's halt großzügig äh äh agiert, so dass es natürlich äh mit anderen Worten
auch ja
Ähm viele Leute oder viele auch auch spezielle Unternehmen oder Branchen äh im Moment. Gerade die Veranstaltungsbranche
natürlich leiden
darunter, dass andere Unternehmen weiter produzieren, die Institutionen hochtreiben und verhindern, dass Veranstaltungen sicher durchgeführt werden, so so das muss man halt auch mal
so aussprechen, ich mein klar, ist natürlich wichtig, dass,
wie gearbeitet und produziert wird und das Land am Laufen gehalten wird, aber.
Der Preis dafür ja ruht finde ich mittlerweile ein bisschen sehr einseitig auf bestimmten Schultern plus dass das Tragische daran ist dass
auch äh ja wenn man auch äh dort in den Bereichen für kurze Zeit mal
eingeschränkt und Kontakte reduziert hätte. Da hätten alle was davon gehabt und so
Ähm ja äh im Grunde genommen ja Lokdown für die Autoindustrie. So Logdown Verlängerung für die Autoindustrie. So das so sieht's halt aus
ähm ja und für die Schulen natürlich.
Und man muss halt auch sehen, wenn's äh wenn es hier sozusagen auch also man könnte ja jetzt sagen.
Hier gibt's ein Recht auf Arbeit. Ja.
So alle beklagen den Verlust von Grundrechte nur das einzige Grundrecht ist du darfst noch arbeiten.
Und äh Firmen dürfen weiter wirtschaften. Es sei denn, es handelt sich um Kultur.
Dann ist es nichts wert, dann ist es, dann ist es gefährlich
ja, dann dann ist es ein Risiko für alle, aber das halt auch in dem so ein Kulturbereich Existenzen existieren, Geld verdient werden Karriere, verfolgt werden und irgendwie äh davon auch schon eine ganze Menge platt gegangen ist,
sehr einseitig. Es ist eigentlich die einzige der einzige Branchenbereich, der komplett tot ist seit einem Jahr, in dem nichts läuft.
Während alle anderen mindestens irgendwie ein bisschen noch überleben du.
Nicht nur im zweiten Weltkrieg war es so schlimm, da wurden auch Partys gefeiert, äh ja, weil da konntest du wenigstens in die Kneipe gehen, ne? Ich habe gesagt, also.
Gastronomie ist natürlich auch äh betroffen, also speziell natürlich so äh Kneipen, die trifft's halt auch super hart, ne? Wobei das äh fast schon.
Für mich schon fast äh sozusagen, dass dasselbe ist, weil dieser ganze Kulturbereich natürlich auch da mit eng verwoben ist.
Manchmal macht sie so im Einzelnen glaube ich relativ wenig äh Gedanken, was es äh für die Leute betrifft. Ne, also gerade die DJs so eine Gruppe, ne.
Ja, das sind Leute, die durchaus was leisten, ne? Es ist äh sieht vielleicht nicht jeder so, ne? Aber die haben bringen eine große kulturelle Leistung und die bringen aber auch äh ja auch ne, eine hohe körperliche Leistung
und die leben eigentlich von zwei Sachen, ne? Auf der einen Seite leben sie von diesen Veranstaltungen, die finden alle nicht statt.
So komplett überhaupt nicht null. Auf der anderen Seite nehmen die dann vielleicht teilweise nicht alle unbedingt in dem Maße, aber viele doch auch von Ausschüttungen der GEMA.
Käma kommt immer ein Jahr später und Kemar lebt von Veranstaltungen.
Und von Kneipen. Von Gastro ja das heißt im Jahr zwanzig zwanzig.
Keinerlei Gemer eingenommen worden über diese Quellen, weder über Veranstaltungen, noch über Ausspielungen in der in gastronomischen Betrieben oder Kneipen oder irgendwas
Also versucht euch mal zu erinnern, wo ihr hingegangen seid, wo öffentlich Musik gespielt wird
Das gab es nicht im letzten Jahr, ja? Außer bisschen so im Sommer, aber natürlich sind dann diese Zahlen geringer.
So, das wird sich dann aber irgendwie äh in diesem Jahr schon in den Ausschüttungen und auch äh und natürlich dann auch in zwanzig zweiundzwanzig in diesen Ausschüttungen noch deutlich zeigen. Das heißt, diese diese Branche ist dann äh doppelt und dreifach gestrafft.
Und das wird natürlich dann auch einen entsprechenden Schaden nehmen
Also da muss man sich schon überlegen, wie man damit jetzt umgeht und es wird glaube ich sehr schwierig sein an dieser Stelle so einem Konzept äh die Zustimmung zu verweigern mit irgendeiner nachvollziehbaren Argumentation.
Und wenn das nicht getan wird, oha, dann rumort's aber kräftig, glaube ich.
Ja. Wenn ja, die, die, wie gesagt, die Schwierigkeit ist
das ist halt ganz schwierig ist, äh, im Moment die Institution tatsächlich für Juni vorherzusagen mit der
politischen Führung, äh, die wir haben, die
ja eigentlich im Moment äh gesehen haben, äh man glauben könnte, dass die die Institutionen absichtlich nach oben treiben, dass sie der Meinung sind, äh es
noch nicht genug äh anders, ja, kann ich mir eben schon sowas wie das Saarland nicht erklären. Äh.
Gut, jetzt müssen wir langsam mal zum Ende kommen. Wir sind schon wieder ganz schön lange dabei. Ähm haben wir noch was.
Noch so ein paar Kleinigkeiten.
Müssen wir jetzt vielleicht nicht drei Stunden drüber äh reden, aber weil's äh auch angemerkt wurde. Wir hatten letztes Mal äh kurz äh ging's um so ein Detail und ich meinte, ja, hier Twitters Red von Feigl Ding
ja äh Erik Feige äh Ding ist
Wissenschaftler, aber nicht unbedingt das so als EP, die Miologe oder Virologe bekannt. Ähm.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ist er jetzt eigentlich genau? Ist irgendwie Arzt, ne? Ähm aber er ist trotzdem in dieser.
Äh Twitter Corona Virus Blase ziemlich aufgefallen und eine ganz interessante Quelle, insofern als dass er die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Papers äh zitiert, raushaut und irgendwie dann in Twitter Trends auch zusammenfasst.
Allerdings.
Sind nicht unbedingt alle über seinen Style jetzt sonderlich äh begeistert, weil er halt auch so den den die Tendenz hat das immer sehr, wie soll ich sagen.
Reißerisch unters Volk zu bringen, ja? Ist ja nicht falsch, sondern ich sage die Art,
sehr auffällig und passt irgendwie nicht so richtig für manche Leute nicht so richtig so der klassischen Wissenschaftskommunikation
Ja, also seine Twitters Trads fangen immer so mit Orkaps an, so, ja. Oh mein Gott.
Genau. Deverstating, nettes Singen, genau. Kritical.
Und ähm schafft's damit natürlich auch eine ganze Menge Aufmerksamkeit auf sich zu ziehen. Also er hat irgendwie seine Twitter-Followerschaft kräftig ähm.
Vergrößert, er hatte, glaube ich, letztes Jahr zweitausend und jetzt ist er irgendwie schon bei fünfhunderttausend. Na ja, dementsprechend.
Kann man natürlich da äh gleich sozusagen sagen, ja okay, was ist denn das jetzt? Ist das irgendwie Alarmismus oder ist das noch Wissenschaft.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin dadurch halt äh durch durch ihn wie gesagt auch viele interessante Papers äh gestoßen und gucke mir die dann natürlich in der Regel auch,
auch an so und ich habe jetzt nichts gefunden äh so von dem, was ich gesehen habe
geschrieben habe, was ich dann halt irgendwie als Quatsch oder Unsinn äh rausgestellt hat und äh ja und ich muss sagen, ich lehne mich ja manchmal auf Twitter auch ein bisschen weit
aus dem Fenster und muss mich dann auch schon mal gelegentlich korrigieren, weil ich da irgendein Detail dann ja.
Nicht richtig dargestellt habe oder zu euphorisch oder so und ich meine,
er war, glaube ich, derjenige, äh der halt sehr früh in den USA gewarnt hat vor äh Corona und äh halt.
Alarm gemacht hat und wie im Januar äh letzten Jahres äh schon
und dafür erst dann total runtergemacht und niedergemacht wurde und dann ist halt doch eingetreten was er.
Wovor er gewarnt hat und äh ja und dann vielleicht er ist vielleicht so eine Art äh ja amerikanischer Antistreg oder so,
der vielleicht tatsächlich ein bisschen mehr äh sagen auf der Seite ist äh ja schon,
ein bisschen mehr Alarm macht so.
Und vielleicht in dem Sinne auch ein bisschen alarmistisch äh ist.
Aber ja eigentlich,
hat Alarmismus bisher noch nicht so richtig geschadet. Problem ist natürlich nur, wenn man dann Alarm macht und das passiert dann nicht so, dass es dann natürlich schlecht so, aber äh bisher
hatten wir wenig solche Gelegenheiten in der Pandemie, dass
nichts passiert wäre so meistens.
Es sei denn es wurde dann tatsächlich was dagegen getan, dann hat's nicht stattgefunden, weil man's verhin.
Genau. Das Präventionsparadox, was natürlich immer gerne in in Raum geführt wird.
Ist ja kaum jemand gestorben. Sterben sowieso jeden Tag dreitausend Leute, zwei bis dreitausend.
Was sind da schon dann ein paar hundert Korona-Tote jeden Tag, so war ja immer die Argumentation nur. Das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach glaube ich hier behandelt und,
klar gemacht, dass ungefähr ja.
Dass tatsächlich nur drei Prozent mit Corona und siebenundneunzig Prozent an Corona sterben nur falls.
Diese Debatte nochmal aufkommen sollte.
Ja, ich denke, es ist auch ganz äh meine
ich will ihn jetzt nicht als irgendwie den Idealtypen für, wie man jetzt kommunizieren sollte, darstellen. Ich habe äh ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so eine
durch fundierte Meinung zu ihm aufgebaut. Mir geht's jetzt auch gar nicht um diesen feigel Dingen, aber was ist ja so ein bisschen mit sich bringt, ist die Frage auf welche Art und Weise sollte man eben dann auch diese
gewisser Wissenschaft oder das geschaffene Wissen äh vertreten und verteidigen,
weil auf der anderen Seite in dieser Schwobler Fraktion von diesen Leuten, die irgendwie äh immer das Haar in der Suppe äh suchen und versuchen, einfach gegen jede Herleitung
Dinge zu behaupten, dann in die Welt zu setzen und Leuten irgendwie sinnlos Angst zu machen, die sind einfach mit Übertreibung und und und Breitbeinigkeit,
kaum noch zu übertreffen. Und insofern ist es vielleicht auch mal ganz okay
wenn man äh dem dann auch was Vergleichbares entgegensetzt. Das muss nicht im selben Style kommen und das das sollte natürlich auf keinen Fall die die selben Fehler machen, dass man irgendwie falsche Dinge darstellt oder so. Aber äh
bisschen mehr mit dem Glas so zu wirbeln als äh die ganze Zeit immer nur so typische wissenschaftliche Studien ähm
Paper, die ihr allein schon dadurch immer so einen Impact vermissen lassen, weil einfach die Titel so langweilig sind.
Dem dann irgendwie auch nochmal eine eine reißerische, aber vielleicht trotzdem korrekte Headline hinzuzufügen, sehe ich jetzt nicht als besonders äh schlimm an,
Mag aber verpönt sein.
Ja? Und mein Wissenschaftler normalerweise kommunizieren ja auch hm mit anderen Wissenschaftlern beziehungsweise die Paper, die geschrieben werden, sind ja.
Nicht gedacht äh so als äh ja allgemeine Literatur,
Und sondern das ist dann natürlich Aufgabe dann von ja im Grunde genommen,
Wissenschaftsjournalisten äh dann diese PayPals dann zu verstehen und die Ergebnisse dann zu präsentieren.
Im breiten Publikum, was auch.
Sehr häufig misslingt, wobei mir aufgefallen ist, dass doch die Qualität der Wissenschaftskommunikation
jetzt während der Panimie zum einen immer besser geworden ist. So, also gibt's glaube ich viele gute Beispiele mittlerweile und das auch mittlerweile natürlich die ganzen Journalisten äh mehr und mehr zu Kovit
Experten äh werden, so wie wir zwangsläufig auch einfach durch Beschäftigung äh mit dem Thema.
Ja ähm und.
Ja das also da scheinen sich aber alle oder nicht alle, aber sehr viele ihrer Verantwortung auch bewusst zu sein und natürlich steht auch immer Glaubwürdigkeit auf dem Spiel und das ist halt,
nach wie vor ein polarisierendes Thema und ähm.
Ja ganz viele Leute wollen's immer noch nicht wahrhaben, dass mein bisschen zum ich komme immer noch nicht drüber hinweg äh über den einen Spieler vorhin ähm aus.
Lasche Buffe.
Mit Laschet so wo ich denke,
einfach nur in in welcher Welt hat er sich's eigentlich bequem gemacht, äh da mit was für Leuten,
umgibt er sich eigentlich, welche
Medien und sonstigen Informationen nimmt er eigentlich zur Kenntnis, dass er irgendwie so einen Spruch rauslassen kann, ja.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, der Mann leidet äh einfach an extrem gestörter Realitätswahrnehmung. Gut. Ähm.
Jetzt kommen wir zum Ende.
Ja sollten wir.
Fazit. Läuft nicht so gut gerade, aber ähm vielleicht.
Läuft Kacke äh irgendwie kann man nur sagen, aber ich habe meine,
Stimmungstiefphase jetzt schon überwunden die war so an dem Morgen als ich aufgewacht
bin und gelesen habe, dass jetzt selbst diese Minimal
Maßnahme so mal eine Woche Kontaktreduktion über Ostern äh dass die dann so von einem Tag auf den anderen über Nacht dann wieder
über Bart geworfen wurde und das war ja.
Da war er bei mir auch echt aus.
Das und irgendwie die Woche davor wie diese Astra Sinica Impfeinstellung, das waren so diese beiden Momente, wo ich mir dachte, so Leute, ich ich kann ja einiges fressen so, ich habe da kann eine storche Uhr entwickeln, das könnt ihr euch überhaupt nicht vorstellen, aber eben
bringt mich wirklich langsam an die Grenze der Belastbarkeit, was diesen ganze mentale Verschwulung betrifft. Also bitte. Kommt jetzt mal klar,
jetzt auch irgendwie eine Woche wo er irgendwie allen erzählen könnt, wie überrascht ihr von diesen Zahlen seid? Und.
In zwei Wochen, denke ich mal, werden wir wieder voll in der äh oh Gott, was sollen wir jetzt tun? Diskussionen drinstecken und da bin ich aber gespannt, was dabei ra.
Und
äh es wurden ja aber auch systematisch jetzt Handlungsoptionen eliminiert. Ja normalerweise ist jetzt eine gute Strategie ganz allgemein, eine, die dir Handlungsoptionen eröffnet oder erhält
ja? Und ähm.
Was wir aber mit dem mit diesem halbgaren ja nicht lockdownlokdown, Leid und dann diese ganze äh ja
ewige Gummiartige.
Lockerungsdiskussion.
Ja, äh beziehungsweise das dieses.
Zerreden, des Zerreden von allem, ja.
Und dann äh ja äh dann gefolgt halt von einem von einem zerreden, gefolgt halt dann von einer komplett inkonsequen
ja Politik wo wo das eine nicht zum anderen passt, wo dann so langsam bestimmte Partikularinteressen immer mehr Gewicht erhalten zu lasten von anderen Gruppen, die sich nicht wehren können, so
komm.
Und äh ja das ist äh das führt dann eben auch dazu, dass halt die Bereitschaft natürlich äh sinkt bei vielen Leuten sich an Maßnahmen zu halten
und dem wird dann jetzt natürlich noch begegnet durch äh ja äh einfach weitere,
Öffnungen oder Verzicht auf auf Maßnahmen und ähm ja nee.
Ähm und dann stellt sich die große Frage, was sollen wir denn dann machen, wenn äh sagen wir, alle Register schon gezogen haben und die Zahlen gehen trotzdem hoch? Ähm ja.
Dann äh sind wir wirklich irgendwann bei dem Punkt, dass äh ja äh wir ähm,
Landkreise abriegeln und Ausgangssperren und Straßen sperren und äh halt äh alles dicht machen müssen, was überhaupt nicht nötig gewesen wäre.
Ja und ich versteh's auch nicht äh so, ich meine, die Engländer haben's im Winter geschafft, B eins eins sieben runterzukämpfen, ohne,
jetzt wirklich komplett alles dicht machen zu müssen, aber die haben halt auch ja bei uns.
Das kristallisiert sich halt immer weiter raus, äh waren halt so äh ich meine, die Schulen.
Auf jeden Fall der Punkt, der immer das Fass zum Überlaufen gebracht hat. Man hätte natürlich alternativ auch mehr Firmen schließen können, statt die Schulen
so, dann hätte man die Schulen offen halten können, aber da Firmen schließen im großen Maßstab halt nicht drin war, äh so
ja
Die Schulen mussten ja nur geöffnet werden, damit die Firmen offen gehalten werden können.
Gut, das kommt noch dazu, dass Kitas und und ja. So.
Dass er so mehr so wie wie so Dienstleister auch für die Wirtschaft angesehen wird und dieses ganze Gerede um, aber die Kinder und die Bildung, das nehme ich denen halt auch einfach nicht ab
Weil wir denen das irgendwie das das ausreichend wichtig gewesen wäre,
dann hätte die Sicherheit auch mal darum gekümmert Filter einzubauen irgendwie digitalen Unterricht aufzubauen, dann hätte man diese Bildung auch wunderbar machen können und äh vielleicht auch mal in anderen Krisensituationen in der Zukunft oder generell einfach mal ein bisschen entspannter,
auch für kranke Kinder zu Hause et cetera PP. Ich will jetzt nicht die ganze Geschichte aufzählen, aber das das scheint mir einfach nicht wirklich das Ziel gewesen zu sein, sondern Schulen und Kitas
sind halt erforderlich, damit die Leute arbeiten können. Und arbeiten ist das Wichtigste.
Vor allem in in Deutschland, wo ein Großteil äh der Leute einen äh
eine Berufsbezeichnung in ihrem Namen trägt, so einschließlich ich. Sowas sind, wenn du dich anguckst, die häufigsten Nachnamen in Deutschland. Ich glaube, so die Hälfte ungefähr so.
Fischer, Müller, Schmidt, Meyer, ähm.
Ach so. Ja.
Äh keine Ahnung ähm ja hm.
Du weißt, dass es schon einen Namen hat, dann braucht man's nicht mehr zu machen.
Nee, nee, das heißt, das äh Arbeit halt offensichtlich äh ja doch ganz wichtig ist.
Event des Individuums ist.
Das ist sozusagen identitätsstiftend oder ein ganz wichtiges Identitätsstiftendes merkt man in Deutschland wahrscheinlich auch in vielen anderen Ländern, aber ich glaube in in Deutschland ganz speziell so ohne Job bist du nichts.
Ohne ohne anständigen Beruf so äh.
Natürlich müssten sie, ja, ist natürlich traurig, dass so viele Leute äh äh sterben mussten und krank geworden sind, aber stell dir mal vor, sie hätten dann nicht mehr arbeiten können.
Wäre viel schlimmer gewesen und meine es zieht sich halt auch durch natürlich ist so Dinge wie
wenn man dann sich so strahlend Schutzgrenzwerte anguckt, stellt man fest, dass die zufällig genauso gewählt sind
dass diejenigen mit der höchsten Strahlenbelastung, nämlich fliegendes Personal,
Ähm dann äh ja trotzdem noch fliegen könnten. So. Ähm ja.
Okay, wir wollen jetzt hier nicht so ein, so einen kompletten äh.
Ja, wir wir.
Reingehen, aber es ist schon also es sind jetzt schon so Aspekte, die sich leider leider auf äh drängen sollen. Wir werden mal gucken,
dieses Land noch in irgendeiner Form zur Besinnung kommt oder ob wir irgendwie wirklich alle Fehler machen wollen, die anderen auch gemacht haben
Lock down ist immer noch möglich, ja? Also äh im guck grade hier nochmal am achtundzwanzigsten Januar, also vor zwei Monaten.
Portugal eine Institanz, die mal locker bei dem zehnfachen von dem von Deutschland lag. Ja? Und.
Die haben's dann halt auch geschafft, innerhalb eines Monats, innerhalb von vier
Wochen unter den Zahlen von Deutschlands zu liegen, wo wir so unser unseren tiefsten Kni
äh jetzt hatten und während sich Deutschland halt langsam wieder nach oben arbeitet, ist Portugal halt mittlerweile niedriger, als wir das irgendwie in der ganzen zweiten Welle waren. Und.
Das wäre alles möglich gewesen. So und es ist halt einfach verspielt worden für für nix, ja. Es wurde die ganze Zeit gesagt.
Wir können das nicht machen, weil Dollar irgendein Grund.
Ja, das ist das Tragische.
Und jetzt können wir es deswegen wirklich nicht mehr tun.
Das Tragische an der ganzen Sache ist.
Dass wir im Laufe der Panemie immer schlechter geworden sind, ja? Statt man denken würde, dass wir Erfahrungen sammeln und in der Lage sind, dann.
Die Zahlen besser zu kontrollieren, ist genau das Gegenteil passiert. So ähm.
Und äh auf der einen Seite ja hat
sich bei der Wissenschaft und auch bei vielen, ich sage mal, Amateuren ein ganz gutes Verständnis mittlerweile für die Situation entwickelt, aber die Profis, die Entscheider.
Ja man jetzt im im Soziologen sprech würde ich jetzt sagen ja das ist halt das Problem so mangelnde,
Antizipations und Adaptionsfähigkeit zentraler Akteure äh deren äh ja äh Wirkmächtigkeit äh,
ihre Wissensmächtigkeit äh halt ähm bei weitem übersteigt. So.
Ja das ist halt das Ding, dass da.
Dass wir uns Entscheider gewählt haben oder Regierende gewählt haben, die es einfach nicht drauf haben, ja? Und äh wenn,
halt jemand nicht richtig rechnen und denken kann, so wie dieser Laschet äh so, dann sollte er doch wenigstens die Eigenschaft besitzen, äh dann.
Leute zu fragen, die das können, ja. Aber ähm ja ähm nee, ich ich.
Findet einfach nicht statt.
Ich komme nicht drüber weg über den Mann.
Das kann ich gut verstehen. Ich verlinke noch einen äh äh einen Kommentar im Spiegel, den fand ich irgendwie auch äh äh sehr passend, der einfach äh wie hieß er der Titel war ähm.
Multiples Politikversagen und der Titel deutsche
Politik taumelt von Corona Gipfel zu Corona Gipfel, sie agiert kaum, sie reagiert nur noch und ihre Prioritätensetzung ist ein Skandal von Markus Feldenkirchen und da hat er dann diesen schönen Satz gesagt und damit können wir das dann, glaube ich, hier auch zu Ende führen.
Mit der deutschen Politik aber steht dem Virus die Verkörperung der Halbherzigkeit mit Hang zur Grundbräsigkeit gegenüber. Ein dankbareren Gegner
könnte sich das Virus kaum wünschen.
Ja. Ja.
Damit ist irgendwie äh alles gesagt.
So Leute, lange Sendung, aber das muss ja jetzt mal sein. Ähm vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, wenn ihr noch zuhört und äh ja.
Ja, war auch mehr mehr Guren als sonst. Ich glaube mehr mehr Emotionen als sonst. Ähm.
Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt auch wirklich an so einem Punkt angekommen. Also bisher haben wir es irgendwie alles begleitet und auch mit einem gewissen Wohlwollen.
Begleitet und so viele Fehler auch verziehen und was haben wir nicht alles erzählt von na ja alles neu für uns und so. Aber jetzt haben wir so ein Jahr durch und ihr habt nix gelernt.
Und es ist alles immer nur schlimmer geworden und jetzt ist einfach dieses Kapital, dieser Vorschuss, der ist jetzt verbraucht. Also ab jetzt.
Braucht man sich, jetzt kann man sich einfach nur noch durch durch positive Entwicklungen und durch durch sinnvolle Maßnahmen und und und treffende Entscheidungen und
Dadurch kann man sich jetzt noch weiterqualifizieren, aber es ist jetzt einfach alles äh alles verbraucht, was was da hätte vorher sein können.
Es gibt auch also ein ein kompletten Mangel an Erfolgsmeldungen so äh an ja ich meine an der Impffront läuft's nicht gut
zwo und äh ja an der Bekämpfungsfront läuft's nicht gut, die.
Wirtschaft läuft nicht gut. Die Schulen laufen nicht gut.
Die Kneipen laufen gar nicht äh und äh äh so ja ein komplettes Desaster äh einfach. Klar,
schlimmer geht immer, aber äh das ist dann das ist dann auch immer so das Ding
äh man vergleicht sich immer gerne mit den Besten, möchte immer gerne Weltmeister sein, aber,
kaum ist man's nicht, äh wird dann werden dann die schlechteren rausgekramt als als Benchmark, äh die ja wo es halt überall schlimmer ist und das ist auch
echt nicht mein Anspruch. Also ich mag
muss sagen, ich mag auch dieses Land eigentlich Deutschland äh so es mir an sich sehr sympathisch so äh vieles, aber.
Da ist was gut zu machen.
Ja, das ist also sozusagen das
ist das geht langsam auf keine Kuhhaut und äh das wird auch das wird Konsequenzen
haben. Da bin ich mir sicher und größere Konsequenzen, als es vielleicht gerade die Leute glauben, so viel glauben ja, AF
wenn's erstmal vorbei ist, ist das Ganze auch schnell vergessen, dann reden wir nicht mehr drüber und so, ne, ne.
Noch das wird uns noch viele Jahre begleiten und wird uns hat uns auch weltpolitisch geschadet. Das hat uns wirtschaftlich geschadet, ja? Äh China,
ne. Äh viele andere Länder auch äh die es halt besser gemanagt haben. Äh ja, haben ihre äh haben.
Wachstum äh hinbekommen so und äh die Leute konnten dort auch
wesentlich freier und angenehmer leben und die Zeit verbringen als wir und dann uns immer, ja, aber das sind ja Inseln und äh wir gucken ja die Grenzen nicht zumachen und Diktatoren und.
Asiaten und so und ja aber am Ende des Tages.
Teilt, dass wir es verkackt haben, so in kolossalen Maßstab völlig unnötig und dabei sind äh
sagen ist mit jedem neuen Anlauf noch schlimmer zu verkacken. So, Entschuldigung für das äh Wort, aber.
Ist so und ich meine wahrscheinlich stehen die da alle schon und kichern sich irgendwie zu, du kannst es ja so machen wie die Deutschen. Das war auch schon mal anders. Also da gibt's noch einiges aufzuholen. Da müssen wir uns noch einiges anhören,
naja gut machen wir jetzt an dieser Stelle äh Schluss. Vielen Dank äh fürs Zuhören.
Oder wer bis hierhin gehört hat äh kann noch drüber nachdenken, ob er auch die Mitterebene unterstützen möchte, den Link findet ihr auch in den Shownotes
alle Links, die wir hier, alle Artikel, die wir genannt haben, alle Paper, alle was weiß ich, alle Twitters, Reds, in den Shownows, unter UKW Punkt.
FM. Vielen Dank und wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder und sagen tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüs.